[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 2 juillet passe
d'armes à l'hôpital martin billetterie
patron de l'ap-hp accuse de professeurs
out de faux témoignages en pause de
déclarations du médecin marseillais lors
de son audition par la commission
denquête sur le co vide 19 une sur le
nombre de morts à paris l'autre sur
l'hospitalisation dès le mois de janvier
20 patients chinois
et si le monde d'après n'était pas aussi
vert que cela l'insee estime que
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
ménages souhaitent fuir les grandes
villes sweet au confinement
mais avec quelles conséquences sur
l'environnement ce boom annoncé de la
rurbanisation alimenter tarnos de
l'épargné des ménages pourrait au final
être plus polluants qu'attendu un
paradoxe pour lequel l'économiste
jacques sapir reviendra tout à l'heure
dans sa chronique
[Musique]
polémique autour du projet bioéthique
qui est de retour à l'assemblée
nationale les députés de la commission
spéciale de bioéthique ont adopté un
amendement visant à autoriser la méthode
dite ropa en france un procédé également
appelé maternité partager et qui est
clairement dénoncée par certains comme
une forme de gpa le pour l'emporter en
russie les électeurs valide la réforme
constitutionnelle à près de 78% une
victoire prouve l émir coup tine le
dirigeant russe a remercié les citoyens
cette réforme les permettra de se
représenter encore deux fois à
l'élection présidentielle l'opposition
dénonce des irrégularités
[Musique]
l'idée raul attaqué de toutes parts
après son audition devant la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale le 24
juin le professeur marseillais est
accusée de mensonge par martin hirsch
directeur de l'ap-hp mais aussi par le
conseil scientifique et la haute
autorité de santé
les détails en son et en image
il me semble essentiel que les travaux
de la commission ne puisse être fondé
sur des éléments factuels m'en faut et
que les suites qui s'imposent puisse
être donnée
la mortalité dans les réanimations ici à
paris dans ce travail toujours est de
43% chez nous à marseille
elle est de 16% nous n'avons aucune
donnée qui place à 43 % la mortalité
dans les réanimations de l'ap-hp d'autre
part il n'y a à ce jour aucune étude
publiée qui analysent comparativement
les taux de mortalité en réanimation
évalué dans des conditions contrôlées
entre les hôpitaux parisiens et
marseillais
le patient chinois de 80 ans s'est
présenté à la pitié salpêtrière il est
rentré chez lui il est revenu sept jours
après elle est venue mourir dans un
hôpital
le seul patient chinois de 80 ans auquel
peut faire référence le professeur
didier raoult et a été admis le 25
janvier 2020 à l'hôpital européen
georges pompidou il n'a jamais été
renvoyé chez lui
m
et
la rigueur scientifique l' indépendance
et transparence sont les valeurs de
l'institution que je préside
je ne saurais accepter que la réputation
de la haute autorité de santé
son sérieux et son intégrité soit remis
en cause
mais alors pourquoi toutes ces attaques
contre didier raoul tess qu'il dérange
fait-on preuve d'acharnement contre lui
ou ses critiques sont elles finalement
justifié c'est ce que nous allons tenter
de comprendre pour en parler nous sommes
avec lionel guérin médecin immunologiste
endocrinologue bonsoir violaine ira
peut-être aussi cofondatrice du
collectif
laissons les médecins à prescrire
philippe froguel à vos côtés chercheur
en nonne en doctrine au logis également
biologie moléculaire et génétique vous
est également professeur à l'impérial
collège de londres et à l'université de
lille 2 bonsoir mais vous aussi fini
progrès merci d'être avec nous alors
martin hirsch a des mots forts patron
des hôpitaux de paris qui accuse
clairement le professeur raoul de faux
témoignages ça vous choque du progrès
oui c'est assez les dix huitième épisode
de déléguer un troll et manta parisien
et didier raoult ce qui est un petit peu
triste c'est qu'ils ont convaincu le
directeur général de l'ap-hp hirsch a
pas de se lancer dans la guerre avec des
informations qui sont fausses en fait
puisque c'est pas un faux témoignage
quel fléau didier raoult il a donné des
informations qui sont vrais ou qui sont
fausses mais qui correspondent à à des
choses qui ont été dites et filmé par
vos confrères de ces news ou de bfm je
les ai regardés tout à l'heure ces deux
informations bien été donnée à la fin du
mois de janvier elles sont peut-être
fausse mais c'est pas du faux témoignage
si ces gens se sont trompés à ce
moment-là bras ou s'est trompé bon il
est rare voire de se tromper mais ce
qu'il a dit a bien été annoncée montrée
à la télévision par dr lacombe le dr
jass band donc c'est beaucoup une
tempête dans un verre d'eau
même diagnostic alors c'est les fameux
chiffres on en parle 1 43 % de mortalité
en réanimation dans les hôpitaux
parisiens c'est ce qu'avait justement
repris le professeur raoul ce sont des
données effectivement qui existe qui
n'existe pas c'est une tempête dans un
verre d'eau m'écoutais je partage
le même sentiment comme mon collègue
premièrement parce que nous avons tous
entendu les témoignages à la télévision
de madame lacombe de monsieur comme et
de différentes personnes en plein milieu
de la crise où effectivement ces
chiffres et est annoncé donc ce sont
quand même des gens qui travaillent à
l'assistance publique de paris qui ont
donc a priori dit des choses exactes
et puis d'autre part bon on sait qu'en
général monsieur raoul qui documentent
plutôt assez bien ce qu'il raconte
je pense que vu l'état actuel de la
crise quand on prend des positions ont
fait ce type d'assertion sait de quoi
l'on parle en général parce que on a
bien compris qu'on était dans l'exposé
potentiellement à des suites juridiques
donc je pense que tout ce qui a été posé
et documentée comment vous expliquez
dans ce cas philippe froguel la posture
enfin la posture je sais pas si on peut
appeler ça une posture d'ailleurs les
propos de martin hirsch est ce qu'il est
dans son rôle il fait son travail où ils
cherchent peut-être aussi à détourner
l'attention c'est que lui aussi a
beaucoup de problèmes sur les bras en ce
moment alors noté richard rappelons le
avait fait une conférence de presse
bidon sur un médicament dit miracle qui
était un inhibiteur de l'interleukine 6
et à cette conférence de presse a
entraîné le conseil scientifique de
l'étude à démissionner donc il a quand
même déjà des choses à se reprocher
martin et je ne sais vraiment pas
pourquoi il s'est lancé dans cette
aventure totalement stupide qui le
dessert alors je ne sais pas si dany été
manipulés ou si le coc vide rend dingue
est à peu près tout le monde
mais là franchement mais de corismo elle
est pourquoi les gays il se lance dans
un combat aussi douteux violaine guérin
effectivement vous c'est quoi votre
analyse sur c'est vrai qu'ils osent en
l'occurrence martin hirsch alors que lui
même voilà à des problèmes gérer mon
idée 10 et qui se passe des choses tout
à fait anormal sur cette crise et
je pense qu'on n'a pas fini de
détricoter tout ce qui est en train de
se passer
il ya énormément de conflit d'intérêts
et c'est pas seulement au niveau
français qu'il faut le regarder je pense
que c'est une problématique mondiale
qu'il faut détricoter il y a des choses
totalement anormal pour la première fois
de ma vie j'ai été menacé parce que je
publié un article sur le sujet en
l'occurrence et témoignant de
l'efficacité de des traitements en phase
précoce azithromycine seul ou
azithromycine plus hydroxy chloroquine
et je suis ravi de voir que hier on
vient d'apprendre qu'on a des résultats
à peu près comparable à ce que tu as une
publication américaine qui vient de
sortir
donc il se passe des choses surréaliste
parce qu'être en tant que chercheur
menacé par des institutions françaises
en l'occurrence est extrêmement
surprenant voilà donc je pense que vous
les journalistes qu'à chaque fois je
vous le dis mais vous avez fait du
travail parce que nous on reste assez
centré sur le côté scientifique bon je
sais que monsieur froguel a beaucoup
communiqué sur la problématique des
tests là aussi c'est totalement
surréaliste qui s'est passé donc voilà
on est dans une problématique très
particulière philippe froguel le conseil
scientifique et la haute autorité de
santé à eux aussi sont sortis du bois et
se sont rangés un petit peu à la vie de
martin hirsch des propos infamants de la
calomnie
il faut dire que voilà le professeur a
honte on entend rarement aussi peu long
de bois devant la commission de
l'assemblée nationale il a clairement
évoqué des des conflits d'intérêts et il
faut forcément se défendre on imagine
que ça plaît évidemment pas tout le
monde hein ces propos alors beaucoup de
médecins voir la plupart des médecins ce
qu'on appelle les leaders d'opinion ont
des relations avec les industriels du
médicament est donc effectivement là une
très grande part des gens qui sont dans
ces comités en on avoir des relations
avec des industriels ne veut pas dire
d'avoir des conflits d'intérêts vous
exactement avoir des conseils potentiel
et ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont vendus à
ces industriels donc moi je ne rentre
pas du tout
dans la discussion complotistes ou
accusant les personnes de ces comités
qui se sont opposés à hydra aussi
coquine en disant qu'ils sont payés par
tel ou tel laboratoire est par contre ce
que je remarque avec la route autorités
c'est quand l'article de lens était
sorti à la haute autorité a donné tout
dessus de santé a donné tout de suite un
avis défavorable à la yves rossy prokin
alors qu'elle n'avait pas lu papier donc
moi je me pose tous des questions pauvre
pas véritablement sur leur honnêteté
mais sera leurs compétences
scientifiques et en l'occurrence là ils
ont montré une très très grande
incompétence scientifique puisqu'ils ont
même pas sûr alors qu'ils ont soit
disant des grands spécialistes ont pas
ils ont pas su voir que les langues
c'est que cette étude était totalement
trafiqués et quelqu'un comme moi qui n'a
absolument aucune compétence dans ce
domaine c'est simplement un scientifique
en lisant adapté j'ai été aperçu mais
s'est bien aperçu que c'était du trafic
et c'était l'acteur fraude
alors ces gens là quand même il faudrait
dire les pompiers avant de les utiliser
pour interdire médicaments c'est vrai
que beaucoup de zones d'ombré sur ses
médicaments votre collectif violaine
guérin d'ailleurs s'était mué dans un
communiqué lundi soir de ce blanc seing
jeu suite accordé par l' agence
européenne du médicament hors md y
virent comme traitement du corps vide ça
veut dire concrètement quaprès on est en
train de faire qu'on a fait une faveur à
un traitement dont l'efficacité n'était
pas nécessairement prouvées de la mairie
écoutez manger par le passé déposé
quelques dossiers des semaines donc je
sais exactement ce qu'il doit y avoir
dans le contenu comment les dossiers
doivent être analysées et donc on est
surtout surpris qu'il n'ait même au vu
de ce qui a été publié sur le sujet et
je suis d'accord avec vous un monsieur
prochaine pour dire c'est le délai
théorique de complotisme c'est pas c'est
ça c'est un vaste mots je pense qu'il ya
des différents centres d'intérêts de
différentes industries pharmaceutiques à
moi je prends une pas spécifiquement
guinée à loup ou autre je pense que
quand une épidémie émergent c'est
l'occasion potentiellement d'ouvrir des
nouveaux marchés c'est donc au niveau de
l'industrie pharmaceutique se travaille
beaucoup en ce moment que ce soit sur
les vaccins les médicaments et tout est
à la limite pourquoi pas si on est dans
l'éthique le respect des patients et
cueillez pas de manipulation ou quoi que
ce soit aujourd'hui on sait non
seulement ému effectivement durée d'une
mm rapide sur le même désir mais
également ému sur le fait qu'il est
toujours impossible d'avoir des données
extrêmement clair sur la soi-disant
toxicité des drogues cycle ans keane et
donc on demande à l'agencé la rfm les
des données claires et quand je dis
clair c'est avec la plus d'habilité
qu'ils ont fait des soi-disant
événements indésirables et aujourd'hui
on n'a pas ces données
or normalement toutes ces données
devraient être accessibles à tous les
citoyens français
en tout cas un docteur n'est pas
d'accord avec vous il s'appelle laurent
alexandre vous me connaissez évidemment
vous avez déjà débattu ensemble
ici on va écouter laurent alexandre qui
était notre invité hier quand il s'est
avéré que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
n'était pas efficace
didier raoul tu pour noyer le poisson a
expliqué qu'il y avait un complot de
gilles ead pour contrer l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et émettent leurs md et vire
à la place
en réalité c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe puisque leur désir n'est pas
prescrit donc il ya une crainte qui a
été montée en épingle par didier raoul
tu es si vous prenez les vidéos youtube
de didier raoul depuis quelques semaines
il y en a beaucoup qui sont consacrés à
gilera ça lui permet de faire oublier le
fait que même aux états unis où trump
avait beaucoup beaucoup plus évident
roxy chloroquine
on l'a retiré des médicaments autorisés
dans le colis de 19
philippe froguel que vous inspirent ces
propos de laurent alexandre cécé didier
raoult et qui crée tout simplement la
polémique et la suspicion
didier raoult a sa propre opinion et sa
propre opinion c'est que ses collègues
qui sont contre et d'occident aucune
leçon parce qu'ils ont des conflits
d'intérêts moi c'est pas mon opinion
en général quand on hésite entre
complotisme machiavélisme et j'irai
chaos et bêtise c'est souvent la bêtise
qui écrirait qui est responsable dans
moi je suis pas je suis pas impressionné
par le niveau scientifique des
différents comités delfraissy ou par les
autres j'ai bien vu ce que ces bêtises
qu'ils ont sortis pour les élections
municipales le premier tour
on les appelait autorisant ce qu'ils ont
fait pour les tests sur les marqueurs
je pense que le vrai problème c'est les
compétences et l'utilité de ces deux
comités la façon dont ils étaient
utilisés par les politiques souvent pour
répéter ce que ce que vous n'allez
politique pour hydroxy chloroquine
j'aurais bien aimé qu'elle soit beaucoup
plus efficace qu'elle ne l'est je sais
tout ça est bien triste parce qu'en
réalité on n'a aucun aucun traitement
miraculeux antiviral actuellement viol
en guerre le mot de la fin parce que ce
qui est mis en cause effectivement cessé
ce que dit le professeur raoul
alors on se pose la question tout
simplement est ce que c'est vrai qu'on
était mieux soigné à marseille qu'à
paris est ce que marseille a eu des des
meilleurs résultats se pose une question
difficile mais c'est la question
finalement assez central moi ce que je
vais vous dire j'ai mon expérience
puisque j'ai soigné des patients avec ce
protocole et quand on avait plus de
claquer nil avec l'azithromycine seul
donc j'ai mon expérience de terrain
parce que monsieur que ce soit monsieur
alexandre où de nombreuses personnes qui
prennent la parole non pas soigner un
seul patient qu'ovide donc mangé mon
expérience clinique je suis médecin
libéral donc j'ai vu les patients 13 ans
maman je les ai pas vus au stade
d'hospitalisation donc mon expérience et
que
les résultats sont extrêmement
intéressants voilà en phase précoce
moi je n'ai pas travaillé en réanimation
donc c'est important aussi de donner la
parole aux gens qui ont pris en charge
des patients tafer philippe froguel le
mot de la fin
votre vue justement sur je pense que le
bilan de didier raoult est pas si
mauvais que ça puisque il a proposé
quelque chose à des personnes qui
étaient en hausse avec une angoisse
terrible qui ont souffert pendant des
semaines tout seul délaissé par tout le
monde puisque là c'est à l'époque on
leur disait de ne pas voir de médecin et
d'appeler le 15
si vraiment il allait mal sans
diagnostic et didier raoult a fait des
tests et sa jolie suis extrêmement
reconnaissant ce qui fait que les gens
savaient ce qu'ils avaient on a ont été
suivis et on leur a donné de new york
cyclo rockin ca service n'a pas servi ça
pas eu d'effets secondaires graves
il a respecté les contre indications et
l'ont fait faire des
électrocardiogrammes je ne sais pas si
ça a été efficace mais ce que je sais
c'est qu'il faut être empathique quand
on est médecin et que quand les gens
souffrent pas il faut les prendre en
charge et à douar qu'à marseille
les gens n'ont pas été pris en charge au
départ de rome il a dit merci à tous les
deux philippe froguel lionel guérin
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et dans l'actualité également si
le monde d'après n'était pas l'hiver que
cela on a beaucoup dit que les français
des grandes villes en manque d'air pur
allaient se ruer sur les campagnes après
le confinement mais avec quelles
conséquences sur l'environnement
ce mouvement annoncé de la rurbanisation
alimenté par une hausse de l'épargné
ménages pourraient au final être plus
polluants qu'attendu on voit ça tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir en
duplex avec nous jeanne bonsoir bonsoir
c'est fini alors jacques commençons par
l'épargné des ménages un con on évoquait
dans quelle mesure les français ont ils
étaient
fournie avant la crise ducobu 19 pas
fourni fourmies oui je comprends bien
je conviens mais oui effectivement les
français se sont avérés être de
véritables fourni fourmis pardon du fait
de la crise du commis 19 et surtout du
fait du confinement
alors il ya plusieurs raisons qui
expliquent cela il ya le fait qu' ils
n'ont pas pu tout simplement acheter ils
n'ont pas pu dépenser leur argent
il y avait aussi la crainte évidemment
de l'après confinement de la crise
économique qui allait venir
mais il ya aussi et ça ça on le voit
c'est un changement structurel dans les
pratiques de consommation
et là il faut bien dire que le
confinement a accéléré plus qu'il n'a
révélé mais il a accéléré un mouvement
c'est le fait que et bien voilà les
français surtout les classes moyennes
qui habitent dans les grandes métropoles
sont tombés amoureux de lecture et de la
verdure
sauf que le mouvement qui en découlent
pourraient être tout sauf écologique
alors justement jacques peut-on chiffrer
ce surcroît d'epargne de la crise du coc
bible oui absolument si on regarde par
exemple les données qui sont fournis par
l'insee bien on voit que depuis vingt
ans nous avons un taux d'épargné qui
oscille entre eux très et demi et 16% si
on revenait un petit peu plus en arrière
par exemple dans les années soixante dix
nous avons atteint un maximum de 21%
alors voit bien que là il ya une baisse
tendancielle du taux des panneaux
autrement dit de la part de l'épargné
dans le revenu des ménages
simplement pour le premier semestre de
2020 eh bien on est remonté à 23%
il y a bien eu de ce point de vue là un
effet confinement alors comment
l'expliquez vous il ya plusieurs
explications à la première est déjà
donné c'est le fait que les ménages
n'ont pas pu dépenser leur argent ils
n'ont pas pu consommer alors on aurait
pu s'attendre à ce que avec la fin du
confinement
ils reprennent voir il ratera la
consommation qui n'avaient pas pu faire
pendant les deux mois du confinement et
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
ben non ils ne le font pas bien sûr
qu'il ya une forte reprise de la
consommation
mais elle reste inférieure au niveau
qu'elles avaient atteint justement en
janvier-février de 2020 après une
deuxième raison c'est ce qu'on appelle
l' épargne de précaution est bien bien
sûr les français sont inquiets pour
l'avenir
et ça peut se comprendre si vous voulez
quand on voit l'ampleur de la crise les
problèmes du chômage qui sont en train
de nous tomber dessus dont on a déjà
parlé dans cette émission est donc
évidemment pour cela et bien ils
constituent un espèce de deux matelas de
précaution un départ mais il ya une
troisième raison et c'est celle là qui
va être intéressant
c'est évidemment le changement de
comportement dans la consommation
alors justement changement de
comportement jacques faut-il croire
cette nouvelle tendance dont parle
beaucoup à nos amis les agents
immobiliers
est ce qu'on y croie faut-il y croire et
bien en fait il ya une étude qui a été
faite par le site de particulier à
particulier
cette étude a été corroborée par
d'autres études qui ont été faites sur
la même chose et on voit qu'il y avait
effectivement un changement changement
il se manifeste par deux choses la
première c'est que il y à bien une
volonté aujourd'hui deux d'acheter un
nouveau bien immobilier que je sois un
appartement ou une maison plutôt des
maisons mais la deuxième chose qui est
extrêmement important c'est que
aujourd'hui
paris est en chute libre en fait la
demande de l'immobilier sur paris
baisse de plus de 10% alors que la
demande qui qui se fait un petit peu
plus loin que paris mais nettement plus
loin que paris donc dans les
départements de la grande couronne voir
au delà vers la normandie ouvert l'yonne
et la bourgogne est bien là la demande
elle explose
absolument alors effectivement jacques
est ce uniquement le chaos en région
parisienne vous nous avez dit que non a
priori non effectivement essayé aussi un
autre aspect extrêmement important on
voyait que ça touche pratiquement la
totalité des métropoles français lyon
bordeaux
mais marseille et nice on voit que tous
les départements qui se situe d'une
certaine manière
au delà je dirais de la sphère immédiate
de la métropole
eh bien ces départements font l'objet
d'une demande extrêmement fort et on
peut le comprendre parce que ça veut
dire que là et bien les ménages pourront
acheter à un prix à peu près comparable
à ce qu'ils avaient dans la métropole à
la fois une maison mais aussi un petit
jardin alors deux mois de confinement ça
donne ça jacques comment expliquer ce
mouvement
oui évidemment la première raison c'est
bien entendu l'impact du continent un
impact du confinement qui a été assez
mal vécue en réalité par la population
si vous voulez parce que bien sûr on
peut pas s'auto confiné nécessairement
dans des belles maisons peut pas s'auto
confinés dans des riads j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de personnalités
people qu'il avait fui et ben non c'est
pas ça la vie des français et bien le
fait que le confinement et était plutôt
mal vécu a donné en réaction cette
demande effectivement pour des logements
essentiellement des maisons
individuelles qui soit à la fois
spacieuse parce qu'il faut de l'espace
en cas d'un nouveau confinement et qui
soit à la campagne tout ça évidemment on
ne peut le trouver qu'en allant dans une
zone de 50 à plus de 100 km loin de la
métropole
et puis une deuxième raison c'est
l'impact du télétravail avec le
confinement les ménages alors
essentiellement les classes moyennes
parce qu'on voit bien que le télétravail
ça peut pas s'appliquer dans toutes les
professions loin de là bon mais pour les
classes moyennes
l'expérience du conte finances a été la
découverte massive du télétravail et
donc les gens se disent bien voilà je
peux travailler à la campagne je ne suis
pas obligé d'être dans une grande ville
pour faire mon travail et mes jacques
quelles seront les conséquences de ce
mouvement
alors oui c'est cela qu'il faut
maintenant regarder à la première
conséquence est bien c'est que
mécaniquement cela va provoquer un
accroissement du parc des voitures
individuelles vous savez quand vous
vivez comme cela
la campagne est bien il faut au minimum
deux voire trois voitures par ménage ce
qui n'est pas du tout le cas quand on
vit dans une métropole
après il y à une deuxième conséquence
qui est tout à fait évidente c'est le
fait que énergétiquement une maison
individuelle est toujours moins
efficientes évidemment à qualité
comparable mais elle est toujours moins
efficientes qu'un petit immeuble et donc
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que non seulement on aura un surcroît de
dépenses en énergie du fait de la
multiplication des voitures mais on aura
aussi un surcroît si vous voulez de
consommation en énergie du fait
justement de cet habitat en maison
individuelle et puis à une troisième
conséquence c'est le fait que ça va
pousser à une individualisation de plus
en plus importante de la société
il faut quand même se souvenir que le
mot citoyen vient de citer que la police
grecque nous a donné aussi la politique
et là on voit bien qu'on va aller vers
une société qui sera de plus en plus
individualisée alors en conclusion
jacques diriez-vous que l'épidémie de
kobe 10,9 à aggraver ton cela oui c'est
ce qu'il faut quand même si évidemment
le pire est loin d'être sûr vous savez
cette épidémie du duc au vide 19
elle va provoquer des comportements qui
vont pas du tout non sens par exemple de
ce qui a été décidé dans la la
commission citoyenne sur le dans la
convention citoyenne pardon sur le
climat et ça risque de nous conduire à
une société qui soit plus individualisée
à une société où des comportements qui
sont extrêmement destructeur en termes
d' usage de l'énergie par la voiture
individuelle 1 par la maison
individuelle vont se multiplier
il était déjà un petit peu le cas avant
le confinement mais voit bien que là il
ya des comportements qui sont en train
de se massifier et puis évidemment il y
à ce très gros problème comment
continuer à faire société et de ce point
de vue là il est tout à fait évidente
il faudra repenser non pas un habitat
individuel mais repenser la fonction des
petites villes et des villages pour
essayer de reconstruire du lien social
et bien jacques le tableau que vous
dressez n'incite guère à l'optimisme
mais il semble réaliste espérons vous
ayez quand même un petit peu tort merci
à vous en tout cas jacques à bientôt sur
rt france dans quelques instants rester
avec nous nous parlerons de la pma qui
fait son retour à l'assemblée un examen
en deuxième lecture du projet de loi
relatif à la bioéthique et l'étude
depuis lundi un nouvel amendement
relance la polémique
et puis direction la russie et la
réforme de la constitution qui a été
adopté avec près de soixante dix huit
pour cent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine
françois vient des mis en cause
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui extrait
tous les peu moins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre c'est
une méthode qui relance la polémique sur
la pma la technique repas a été adopté
par les députés de la commission
spéciale bioéthique qualifié aussi de
maternité partager elle s'adresse aux
couples de femmes
elle consistait à inséminer nouveau
succès condé l'une des femmes dans
l'utérus de l'autre si en octobre 2019
lors des premiers votes sur la question
le verdict avait été défavorable à
l'adoption de l'amendement cette fois ci
il est bel et bien rentré dans la loi
mais certains députés ont dénoncé une
pratique trop proche de là j'ai fait
sans part aux commissions spéciales pour
le projet de loi bioéthique à
l'assemblée nationale
constant lucide et tant décrié le parti
chrétien démocrate n'a cessé d'alerter
sur l'étape d'après contenus dans
chacune des évolutions dit de progrès
ivg pa acc pma et maintenant avec repas
c'est la gpa
oui l'homme est en péril interdire à une
femme de faire don de ses ovocytes à sa
partenaire et à cette dernière dans
portait l'embryon n'est rien d'autre que
du paternalisme de mauvais aloi
cette méthode permet de maximiser les
réussites d'une fiv et doit être
autorisée la majorité vient d'adopter un
amendement d'une gravité extrême car il
ouvre subrepticement la porte à la
légalisation de la gpa
nous combattrons fermement contre intel
funeste projet est donc une forme de gpa
vient d'être votée
menteur la république en marché ce
gouvernement non madame annie est-il cet
amendement ne permet en aucun cas
l'ouverture de la gpa l'arpa permet
uniquement à une femme de porter long
brion de sa compagne tout comme pour les
couples hétéros quand on prélève les
spermatozoïdes pour procéder à une fiv
dont bénéficiera les pouces et pour en
parler nous sommes justement avec annie
est-il que l'on a vu réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux député de l'oise groupe
u10
et indépendant bonsoir anne est-il merci
d'être avec nous en direct par téléphone
la méthode repas qui a donc été adoptée
par l'assemblée
aujourd'hui vous vous dénoncez en gros
une antichambre de gpa qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui vous gêne il ya tromperie
en vous clairement de la part du
gouvernement
oui bonjour tout à fait je maintiens je
persiste et signe c'est une forme de gpa
qu'est ce que l'art par les nos
concitoyens non non non non pas
conscience j'étais dans un couple de
femmes clairement at on l'a la femme a
et la femme b la femme b qui n'est pas
stérile qui pourrait que qui ne présente
aucune virilité porte l'enfant issu des
ovocytes de sa compagne la femme a et
évidemment des spermatozoïdes de
donneurs voilà en clair évidemment on me
dise et altruiste c'est pas pour
quelqu'un d'étranger c'est pour eux mais
mais c'est tout de même porter un enfant
qui n'est pas le sien qui un prêt
d'utérus
évidemment il n'y a pas de contrat mais
c'est évidemment vous dites
l'antichambre c'est une forme de gpa
là j'étais assez gestation pour autrui
c'est à dire porter un enfant pour un
autre
alors on dit c'est pas un autre fait eux
mêmes et mais c'est l'autre femme
imaginez qu'il y ait séparation entre
les deux la seule différence c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de contrat j'ai fait la seule
différence avec une gpa donc dans en
2025 on peut savoir qu'ils nous diront
la gpa éthique parce que la différence
avec la gpa tout couvrir l'aspect
éthique ce sera le manque de contrats
ont dit très altruiste c'est par amour
pour l'autre mais c'est une forme de gpa
je maintiens oui alors la majorité vous
a répondu on l'a vu dans le petit sujet
précédent en disant non non ça existe
chez les hétérosexuels mais clairement
pour vous il ya une forme de tromperie
sciemment de la part de la majorité
aujourd'hui bien sûr bien sûr dont on
sait parfaitement aux cette majorité
veut aller il faut continent en 2020 en
2025 club la prochaine révision de loi
bioéthique ce sera pour la gpa
nous avons échappé de très près pour
pour la gpa pour personne tranchant pour
la gpa post mortem
ils font le minimum deux semaines de
sorte qu'on puisse passer après le reste
ça c'est un premier pas vers eux vers la
gpa l'argument ne tient pas la route
l'argument comme donneront réponse
d'ailleurs a été aussi voté la gpa pour
les enfants nés à l'étranger une
reconnaissance alors alors pareil qu'est
ce que c'est ça ce sont des personnes
qui ont bravé la loi du pays inquiets
qu'ils n'avaient été est illégal en
france
il voulait tout de même en faire donc
ils ont bravé la loi du pays ont fait
quelque chose qui est interdit en allant
à l'étranger pour le faire parce qu'à
l'étranger
c'est permis et ensuite ils reviennent
en france mais on nous dit faut
sécuriser l'enfant mais il n'y a pas
besoin de ces durées des enfants il est
tout à fait figurer les enfants il a un
acte de naissance américains
c'est en réalité c'est pour aider et
faciliter la vie des parents mais
l'enfant lui il a un acte d'essence
américains etc c'est tout à fait bien
simple on est toujours là dans
satisfaire le désir d'adultes et jamais
au grand jamais on ne pense aux enfants
l'enfant élève et de sécurité n'a pas de
problème l'enfant créé encore pour aider
les adultes
je voudrais qu'on pense beaucoup plus
aux os enfants on ne pense pas aux
enfants
on ne fait que satisfaire un désir
d'adultes
nous sommes en train de construire une
grande société gouvernée par les chefs
désir individuel alors à niasse il ce
qui retient l'attention c'est que
finalement aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
vraiment fait les gros titres de la
presse par quelques articles d'ailleurs
aucun membre du gouvernement n'était
présent pour cet examen de ce projet de
loi bioéthique par la commission
spéciale de l'assemblée nationale ça dit
quoi syndic finalement c'est une loi qui
mérite pas plus de débat que ça c'est
absolument scandaleux vraiment scandale
et c'est une loi qui remet en cause tout
le droit de la filiation qui va faire
naître des enfants sans père n'est ce
pas qui change tout signé des au logis
l'heureux leur idéologie ça leur plaît
pas mais c'est la suivante c'est qu'il
considère que le père est une fonction
c'est à dire que ça peut être assumée
par n'importe quelle personne
une voisine un voisin
donc une grand mère que sais-je or or
nous considérons que le père n'est pas
une fonction que le père est un homme ça
change tout c'est une loi qui qui qui
changent vous dit de droit de la
filiation il y à il ya effectivement les
les la recherche sur l'embryon des
embryons chimérique aussi vous savez ce
se mélangent aux cellules souches anima
anima les cellules humaines
mais au niveau de la pma ou en tant que
législateur nous allons faire venir
sciemment des enfants orphelins de terre
tout de même est ce que c'est notre rôle
ça pose de grandes questions est ce
qu'on est là pour satisfaire mes désirs
personnels ou pour légiférer pour un
corps social parce qu'à force de
satisfaire des désirs personnels
c'est la loi du plus fort chacun tire de
son côté nous nous sommes en train de
dévier au niveau législatif pour
satisfaire une poignée d'individus se
cette fête cet individualisme ne
conduira à des endroits où on ne veut
pas aller mais c'est scandaleux aucun
membre du gouvernement en ce moment la
priorité après cette grosse crise nous
convie devra être l'emploi devrait être
l'économie et pas du tout la bioéthique
pas du tout demandez aux à la population
si si la priorité c'est de faire venir
des enfants sans père ou de considérer
que le père est une fonction est pas un
homme mais ils ont eu la préoccupation
doit être ailleurs on nous annonce
peut-être plus de 22 % de chômage dans
l'oise et je vais je airbus la à
toulouse et nantes promet aussi quelques
chômeurs c'est pas du tout une priorité
or or ça touche des sujets éthiques
d'une importance capitale qui toof
l'être humain on est en train de faire
une noire merci anja style en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
pour sauver l'économie française en
pleine pandémie des milliards d'euros
ont été distribués quoi qu'il en coûte
selon les mots d' emmanuel macron il ya
quelques semaines que leur interrogation
aujourd'hui qui va payer la dette
publique la france devra-t-elle la
rembourser elle se creuse en tout cas
largement 100 % du pib avant la pandémie
elle pourrait dépasser désormais les
120% la cour des comptes appelle ou un
redressement structurel pour régler la
facture sans politique d'austérité les
élus de la france a soumis des mre a
annulé cette bête alors faut-il
s'inquiéter de son envolée éléments de
réponse avec l'économiste christophe
rave en plus la dette est importante et
plus au fait il est facile de la
maîtriser si vous voulez pour que la
dette se réduise pas ce que c'est bien
qu'elle se réduisent l'époque la dette
publique se réduisent il suffit que
comment dire que le comment dire que le
rapport entre il faut que déficit public
de chaque année soit inférieure aux
rapports entre le comme dire la dette
publique 100 % hier 101% demain et puis
le croit d'agglo taux de croissance
nominal
si vous voulez prenons l exemple mettre
si vous avez 4 % de croissance nominale
c'est-à-dire 2% de croissance réel et
puis 2% d'inflation et que vous avez une
dette publique de comment dire de 220%
et bien si vous êtes un déficit qui est
inférieur à 4 vers lui pour cent ce qui
est déjà beaucoup
et bien en fait autour d'elle se réduit
donc la question qui se pose un jour
revenir là dessus
aujourd'hui la dette c'est pas un
fardeau
direction l'afrique du sud à présent une
manifestation ait lieu à johannesburg
entre les premiers essais humains du
potentiel vaccin contre le corona virus
laisser fait partie du programme
développé par l'université d'oxford en
angleterre quelques 2000 volontaires sud
africains devraient y participer
cela va à l'encontre de tous les
protocoles et même si les gens vont
consentir il doit y avoir un
consentement éclairé
c'est une forme de violation du corps
d'une personne c'est une forme de viol
ce n'est pas acceptable nous pensons que
notre gouvernement ne soutient pas la
médecine traditionnelle ne reconnaît pas
non plus le travail des guérisseurs
traditionnels parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de médicaments que les
guérisseurs traditionnels pourraient
produire et qui pourrait aider avec le
colis de 19
nous pensons donc que le gouvernement ne
soutient pas la médecine traditionnelle
le kremlin se félicite d'un triomphe à
près de 78% les russes sont largement
prononcés en faveur de la réforme
constitutionnelle voulue par vladimir
poutine et s'est achevée hier au terme
d'une consultation populaire étalée sur
une semaine pour éviter une trop forte
affluence dans les bureaux de vote le
président du secours a donc effectué
deux mandats supplémentaires à partir de
2024 c'est l'un des quarante six
amendements sur lesquels les russes se
sont prononcés à mousse ou les
précisions de notre correspondant
antoine claireaux les résultats ont été
annoncés par la commission électorale
centrale et après le dépouillement de
l'intégralité des bulletins de vote
exprimés
ces amendements ont été soutenus par un
peu moins de 70% pour être exact 77 92 %
en faveur donc de ces amendements contre
21,27 contre dans le détail seuls une
région à en majorité voté contre sézanne
ans il s'agit du district autonome des
nenets hills situé dans l'extrême nord
de la russie la région de moscou par
exemple a voté un peu plus de 65% en
faveur de ces amendements le taux de
participation s'élève à quasiment 68%
non loin du seuil officieux des 70%
alors aucun seuil de participation
n'était requis pour valider ce scrutin
il fallait seulement que ces amendements
soient soutenus par un peu plus par un
peu plus de la moitié des électeurs qui
se sont présentés à leur bureau de vote
on vient de le voir c'est bien le cas
ces amendements sont donc officiellement
adopté vous l'avez dit vladimir poutine
aura donc la possibilité de se présenter
pour deux mandats supplémentaires à
partir de 2024 mais il ya eu bien
d'autres amendements de confirmer
d'adopter via ce référendum la gare la
constitution garantit désormais que le
salaire minimum soit supérieur au
minimum vital et garantit également
l'indexation des retraites sur la place
y ont tous eu toutes celles ci toutes
ces mesures étaient attendues par une
large part de la population russe prêt
pour le premier ministre russe michail
mitch austin le succès de ce référendum
impose de nouveaux objectifs au
gouvernement tu es vachement bon savoie
après le référendum d'hier sur les
amendements à la constitution qui a
confirmé que la société soutenait la
voie de développement du pays proposé
par le président le gouvernement fait
face à de nouveaux objectifs pour le
développement de notre pays dans tous
les domaines
la responsabilité personnelle de chacun
d'entre nous dans le cadre de son champ
d'action est ainsi renforcé mon chat
botté et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct par téléphone avec eugène berg
ancien diplomate spécialiste de la
russie bonsoir merci sur rt fond c'est
clairement un pari gagné pour la dîmière
comptines tout à fait parce que quand on
lit les pronostics ou plutôt les les
évaluations faites par les meilleurs
experts dont arnaud dubien le directeur
de l'observatoire franco russe
il disait que on voulait une
participation supérieure à 50% a été de
65 et à taux d'approbation d'alors de
soixante dix il s'établit à 77,4 la
douce et même certains sondages avant
disait 75-76 donc ou point de vue
les résultats ont été obtenus et
participations et taux d'approbation
alors c'est un amendement il faut le
préciser c'est important qui permettra
d'admirer cousine de se représenter en
2024 mais aussi en 2030
oui ça c'est l'une des hypothèses c'est
disons l'une des discussions parmi les
46 alors là aussi je crois qu'il faut
être avoir les pieds sur terre et
réalise l'ensemble de la presse a dit
voilà poutine avis c'est qu'ils
cherchent à faire élire ses probables
personne lançait ressort en 24 en tout
cas il ya encore quatre ans attend de
patience
ce qu'il veut surtout s être maître des
horloges maître du calendrier il a dit
lui-même
si moi je ne présente pas et bien il y
aura là une espèce de pression il y aura
une lutte d'influencé
les clans parce qu'ils existent partout
vont dégainer un petit peu et c'est pas
du tout favorable à la période actuelle
puisque il a dit là dans son interview
avant la grande parade ce que la russie
cherche comme beaucoup de pays c'est la
stabilité la sécurité la prospérité
alors évidemment il est le mieux placé
pour assurer cette triade
mais en attendant il veut calmer le jeu
et il veut surtout savoir si
éventuellement il se représente 6 choisi
un successeur
pour l'instant quelques noms circulent
on a vu par exemple maire de moscou
sergueï sobianine qui est d'ailleurs
qu'était son son son secrétaire général
c'était le premier pas il a très bien
géré la crise du colis de 19
il ya également le miz la défonce un
homme très proche populaire il y aurait
même un ancien collaborateur est
accessible le dis donc il ya des noms
qui circulent mais prudence
son nom est loin le fait est que poutine
reste malgré d'ailleurs un taux
d'approbation qui a baissé là il faut le
dire
levada le centre indépendant a signalé
que son taux d'approbation est tombé de
79 60
c'est vrai que c'est bas mais pour un
dirigeant occidental c'est le rêve c'est
le paradis et attention ces sondages
c'est très bien ce qu en fonction de la
conjoncture
la passe est difficile pour tous les
pays pour la réussir en particulier
puisqu'il lui quand même cette chute des
prix du pétrole
il ya eu ce chômage maintenant il ya une
reprise dont le tourisme galgut si moi
je connais les agences de voyages qui ne
peuvent pas envoyer moi même je devrais
faire partie du groupe d'observateurs
internationaux ça a été annulé au
dernier moment donc voyez les
circonstances ne sont pas simples pour
la russie comme pour beaucoup de pays le
cas le résultat est là l'opposition gène
berg en tout cas dénoncé des
irrégularités ils sont dans leur rôle on
imagine votre réaction
je suivrai que les circonstances n'ont
pas été conformes j'allais dire aux
normes de nos vieilles démocraties
occidentales mais la russie ne se situe
pas là elle a fait les circonstances est
un pays extraordinaire
alors évidemment on peut se gausser on a
fait des urnes dans les jardins dans les
caddies des supermarchés
voilà bon est ce qu'il ya eu
manipulation
peut-être peut-être mais ça a été
marginal bon peut-être effectivement on
peut gloser fini si tous ces votes ont
été un petit peu arraché il ya eu des
tombolas eu des choses comme ça mais
c'est radicelles en russie les gens
votent comme ça et donc je crois qu'il
faut pas s'attacher uniquement ça
peut-être c'est une petite tache mais
elle cache pas l'ensemble des résultats
c'est ça qu'il faut voir
alors que des gens ne voient que la
petite tâche et ne voit pas le résultat
merci beaucoup aux jeunes d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france merci
à vous
crise diplomatique entre la turquie et
la france de l'espionnage du trafic
d'armes chaque parti accuse l'autre
dernier fait en date ankara qui arrêtent
quatre personnes accusés d'espionner
pour le compte des français de son côté
harry accuse la turquie de violer
l'embargo sur les armes en libye et la
soupçonnent d'être responsable d'un
incident naval dans le cadre d'une
opération de l'otan on le rappelle où
les deux pays sont alliés est la france
quitte donc cette opération françois
tisseau mettre un coup de projecteur sur
l'ambiguïté d'une opération anti trafic
dans laquelle il ya des traficant c'est
l'objectif affiché par le ministère
français des armées
après avoir pris la décision de se
retirer temporairement de l'opération de
sécurité maritime de l'otan qui se
déroule actuellement en mer méditerranée
nous avons décidé de retirer
temporairement nos moyens de l'opération
6 guardian il ne nous paraît pas sans de
maintenir des moyens dans une opération
censée parmi ces différentes tâches
contrôler l'embargo en libye avec des
alliés qui ne respectent pas sans la
nommer la france vise implicitement la
turquie le dernier épisode une escalade
entre les deux pays qui a débuté lundi
après les déclarations du président
français manuel macron évoquant la
responsabilité historique est criminel
de la turquie en libye paris accusant
gars a dit violer l'embargo sur les
armes en livrant des équipements
militaires au gouvernement d'union
nationale est d'acheminer des milliers
de mercenaires syrien réplique immédiate
d'ankara qui dénoncent l' approche
destructrice de la france en libye et
reproche à paris son appui au général
haftar la france que macron dirigent ou
plutôt qu'ils n'arrivent pas à diriger
en ce moment ne se trouvent en libye que
pour poursuivre ses intérêts avec une
mentalité destructrice d'un côté l'otan
considère la russie comme une menace
mais de l'autre la france membre de
l'otan s'efforcent de renforcer la
présence de la russie
il faut regarder avec honnêteté ce que
dit la france à propos de ce qu'il s'est
passé en méditerranée la france n'a pas
dit la vérité ni à l'union européenne ni
à l'otan il n'est pas vrai que nos
bateaux ont visé les navires français
nous l'avons prouvé sur la base de
documents et de rapports la décision de
la france de se retirer de l'opération 6
guardian est aussi un moyen de pression
sur l'hôte en juger par paris pas assez
sévère avec la turquie dans la sphère de
la frégate française courbet le 10 juin
dernier au large de la libye alors
qu'elle était placée sous commandement
de l'otan
la frégate a été visé par les radars de
tirs d'une frégate turque escortant un
cargo soupçonné de transporter des armes
vers tripoli à la suite des
protestations de la ministre française
des armes et florence parly l'otan avait
décidé le 18 juin d'ouvrir une enquête
enquête qui dans son rapport évite de
pointe et une faute turque sans passer
par l'otan la france un moyen
supplémentaire d'accroître sa pression
sur la turquie
le 13 juillet prochain à la demande de
paris les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères se réuniront pour
débattre de nouvelles sanctions contre
ankara pour ces forages gaziers dans les
eaux territoriales de chypre
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons la france qui a été
condamnée par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour des conditions
inhumaines d'existence envers des
migrants puis nous parlerons de la
députée delphine batho qui souhaite elle
réduire avec son comparse françois
ruffin le trafic aérien doit-on limiter
nos voyages pour sauver la planète ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas défini ci d'aujourd'hui en france
l'écho et les violences existait avant
leur confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre l'état sur les
taux des féminicides a plus que je dis
pas doublé mais bien monté forcément on
n'a pas encore tous les chiffres
officiels c'est très difficile gros
n'est jamais nommé loi finalement c'est
le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux et pas à 3
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
principe même de notre association c'est
de réduire les inégalités d'accès à la
santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck faire que
ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
m
en pleine crise du coroner viol après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des étapes l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique
une véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et romain la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir
et comme les choix sont multiples mais
tout le problème va être de bien choisir
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
à
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types préoccupe
bien avant que le match ne commence en
effet par sénégal la chloroquine
domaniale utilisé pendant des décennies
et des décennies ça pourrait faire
sourire les sénégalais quand j'entendis
il n'y a pas de signes qui mettent en
doute ces protocoles
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien giant max hoarau
ni la gravité de la pandémie il a été
élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
vous
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans sa
cuisine des bâches me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de vaccins cuisinier
au tour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
groupe d'avants il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver
on sait que ça allait me rendre plus
tolérante et ben ça m'a rendu plus
intolérante
alors parfois elle c'est vrai vous posez
justement délirer autour d'un dessert
que j'ai appelé la pêche
l'abattage je voulais vraiment montrer
que le monde d'après il serait aussi
dynamique et tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 2 juillet des conditions
inhumaines et dégradantes des demandeurs
d'asile en france c'est ce qu'estime la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme la
haute juridiction condamne l'état à
verser des indemnités à trois requérants
c'est la quatrième condamnation la
france par la cee dh en moins d'un mois
vers un quotas carbone par personne pour
lutter contre la pollution du trafic
aérien
deux députés delphine batho et françois
ruffin ont déposé mardi une proposition
de loi objectif limiter le nombre de
vols domestiques en instaurant un
système de points par voyageur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prendra-t-il fin le
11 juillet vote décisif ce soir à
l'assemblée nationale les députés
doivent se prononcer sur ce projet de
loi qui organise cette sortie mais un
texte rejeté ce matin par le sénat a été
jugé trop liberticide
la course est lancée en côte d'ivoire le
pays a clôturé ces listes électorales ce
mardi à quatre mois de l'élection
présidentielle
une question est dans tous les esprits
qui succédera à alassane ouattara au
pouvoir depuis dix ans parmi les
candidats l'ancien président henri konan
bédié du parti démocratique
[Musique]
la france condamné par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme la
juridiction de strasbourg estime que
paris a manqué à ses obligations en
laissant à la rue plusieurs demandeurs
d'asile dans des conditions je cite
inhumaines et dégradantes
il s'agissait en l'occurrence d'un
afghan d'un bus et d'un iranien âgé de
27 33 et 46 ans la cour a alloué de
10000 à 12000 euros
ces trois requérants c'est la quatrième
fois que la cod h condamne la france en
moins d'un mois écouter le jugement de
ce traitement les autorités françaises
ont manqué à leurs obligations
elles doivent être tenus pour
responsables des conditions dans
lesquelles les requérants se sont
trouvés pendant des mois vivent dans la
rue sans ressources sans accès à des
sanitaires ne disposons d'aucun moyen de
subvenir à leurs besoins essentiels et
dans l' angoisse permanente d'être
attaqué et volé les français devront ils
bientôt limiter leurs déplacements
aériens sept en tout cas le souhait des
députés delphine batho et françois
ruffin qui ont déposé il ya deux jours
une proposition de loi en ce sens le
texte prévoit d'instaurer un quota
carbone individuel annuel de transport
aérien
il prendrait en compte le nombre de
kilomètres parcourus la catégorie
confort et la performance énergétique du
service aérien proposé l'objectif vous
l'aurez compris est de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre liées
notamment aux déplacements de loisirs on
rappelle que les transports aériens ne
représente que 2 à 3% des émissions de
co2 dans le monde est alors doit-on
limiter nos voyages pour sauver la
planète est ce vraiment efficace en
termes d'environnement où cette
proposition était une atteinte aux
libertés individuelles
c'est la question de notre face à face
ce soir
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec philippe muray re économise bon
sport philippe murray remercie d'être
avec nous à ses côtés sergio coronado
ancien député europe ecologie les verts
de l'étranger bonsoir à vous aussi sage
et au canada merci d'être là alors il
faut contraindre les compagnies et leurs
passagers aux enjeux climatiques
on est désormais dans la contrainte
c'est ce que souhaitent les écologistes
sergio coronado la question du
réchauffement climatique est une est un
défi pour l'ensemble de l'humanité je
fasse ça fait quand même des décennies
en fait qu'on en parle et que la
population est en train de prendre
conscience
finalement du défi que nous avons à
recompter et qu'on n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui véritablement à saisir je
vous rappelle tout simplement pas
d'homme que les objectifs de la cap 21
qui s'est tenu à paris aujourd'hui ne
sont pas respectés que la plupart des
pays du g20 n'ont pas respecté ses
engagements qui ne sont pas
contraignants et donc en effet il ya une
série de décisions qu'il faut prendre et
on peut prendre appui par exemple sur
les préconisations qui ont été faits par
la convention pour le climat qui a vendu
ses travaux à emmanuel macron et la
question des transports ont fait partie
les transports représentent dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
l'avez dit un pourcentage en tout cas de
2 30 pensant donc essentiellement de
temps
oui dans ce pourcentage l'autre le
trafic aérien est pas assez importante
ça c'est autour de 3 4%
mais c'est vrai que la croissance du
trafic aérien est inquiétante
vous me parlez de contraintes mais dites
moi par exemple en période de sécheresse
quand on est interdit de remplir sa
piscine au de limiter sa consommation
d'eau c'est une contrainte qu'on qu'on
n'impose au nom du bien commun
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de quoi il
s'agit de rendre rationnelle
l'utilisation de du trafic aérien
et c'est pas une atteinte aux libertés
individuelles il s'agit pas de les
interdire s'agit pas d'interdire il
s'agit par exemple de décider qu'un
certain nombre de déplacements peut se
faire autrement qu'en avion
je rappelle par exemple
les retours paris marseille c'est 40
fois plus émetteurs de gaz à effet de
serre que l'utilisation du tra pour le
même trajet voilà que un canal et
retours paris new york
ça consomme énormément de co2 à aimer
beaucoup de co2 c'est l'équivalent d'une
année de consommation de co2 de
l'habitation d'une personne voyez à peu
près les proportions c'est qu'est-ce qui
est en débat aujourd'hui je conclurai
pour permettre mon contradicteur
d'intervenants qu'est-ce qui est en
débat c'est à dire un certain nombre de
trajets de 2h30 3h 4h doivent être
supprimés au bénéfice du train qui est
beaucoup moins polluant la promotion qui
est fait par exemple ce matin par
l'ancienne ministre de l'environnement
d'être une bateau consiste à dire
finalement tout le monde ne prend pas
l'avion les classes supérieures sont
sur-représentés dans le trafic aérien
les cadres notamment et donc on va
décider on peut en débattre en tout cas
que nous aurions une sorte de carte de
crédit d'émission carbone pendant la
durée d'une année et que vous ne pourrez
pas l'utiliser aussi souvent que l'on
veut on sait par exemple que 30% des
français l'ont taxé à l'avion il ya des
20 % de notre population de nos
concitoyens qui n'ont jamais pris
l'avion et les gens volent pardonnez moi
parce que c'est un débat qui est fait
pour durer donc on vous répondre on aura
l'occasion de décliner tous ses idées
évidemment sergio coronado philippe
muray re déjà sur cette question on
commence par le début des des quotas
votre réaction vous c'est des quotas
d'abord en france dont on parle c'est
pour qu'on parle de sauver la planète
mais les français vont pas sauver la
planète tout seul
l'autre chose qui est importante c'est
que effectivement on parle de baisser
les émissions de co2 en utilisant un peu
moins les transporte fossiles
or qu'est ce qu'on remarque dans les
politiques écologiques qui sont proposés
notamment par europe ecologie les verts
notamment ou peut-être la france a
soumises apparemment c'est qu'on nous
parle de d'interdiction des voitures à
bordeaux on nous parle de passage au
vélo qui est un petit peu obligatoire et
un peu autoritaire
on nous parle maintenant de quotas de
co2 pour l'avion or le quota de co2 ça
veut dire qu'en fait c'est des tickets
de rationnement
en fait on revient à des choses qu'on a
oublié depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
et là dessus on est dans une vision
autoritaire je trouve et on oublie un
peu la liberté or le problème qu'il ya
c'est que si vous voulez en plus ça n'a
aucune ambition écologique
tout ça c'est pas grand chose que vous
proposez en faisant ce genre de choses
parce que le but qu'il n'est pas de
baisser de 10 % les émissions de co2 de
la france
en b en rognant un peu sur la liberté de
déplacement des français de façon
générale c'est une vision dont il manque
complètement d'ambition mois dans le
livre que j'ai fait et qui sort comment
réaliser la transition écologique un
défi passionnant
je montre qu'on peut passer de
l'économie pétrole à une économie
hydrogène et donc arrêter complètement
les émissions de co2 à 20 ou 30 ans mais
pour ça il faut de l'ambition
ceci est totalement positif pour
l'économie et pour l'écologie sans
altérer la liberté et cet hydrogène nous
sommes capables de le faire en mettant
en route beaucoup plus de production
d'électricité sans co2 à partir du
nucléaire à partir de solaire à partir
des eaux lien en produisant dans des
électrolyseurs on a des voitures à
hydrogène c'est pas une vision futuriste
y en a déjà quatre de série
mercedes bmw s'y intéressent peugeot
passe à la voiture une reviennent en
2021 aussi ils pensent tous que c'est
beaucoup plus prometteur que la voiture
écrit que ça se remplit très simplement
on aura bientôt des bus à hydrogène il y
à des camions hydrogène nous aurons des
avions est trop jeune à 15 20 ans donc
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant c'est
beaucoup plus puissant si on le fait que
du protectionnisme intelligent donc pas
dans une modernisation sauvage ça va
créer un million d'emplois directs en
france deux millions d'emplois indirects
et là je peux vous dire que tous les
français seront pour ce genre de choses
alors que le ticket de rationnement
franchement ça fait pas grand chose et
c'est privatifs de liberté
sergio coronado effectivement est-ce
qu'il faut pas accélérer justement la
recherche pour j'imagine évidemment
qu'on s'y attellent déjà
mais pour créer des avions plus vert et
qui peut-être éviterez le désarroi qui
est en train de traverser ce secteur de
l'aéronautique avec ces suppressions
d'emplois en masse oui enfin je suis un
peu surprise la suffisance de mon
interlocuteur ça fait des décennies en
fait que le débat sur la diminution des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre a lieu
et notamment chez les économistes chez
les grandes organisations de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique dont
des organisations internationales comme
le giec et ce gars explique torah livre
non mais laissez moi finir je vous ai
pas 1,4 en août avait semble-t-il un
livre à promouvoir donc vous permettez
toutes les outrances et katrina donc non
mais vous allez promouvoir vous
inquiétez pas dans notre métier vous ce
qui ce qui est proposé depuis fort
longtemps en fait c'est plusieurs le vit
c'est dévié par là même la diminution de
la consommation de viande parce que
c'est très émetteurs la production de
viande c'est très émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre c'est la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments c'est un autre
levier l'aménagement des centres villes
c'est un autre levier on est toujours
face aux aux opposants fait de la
transition écologique qui se drapent
d'une toile plus verte que nous refuser
que le tueur on aime on a toujours
affronté une critique l'écologie
punitive l'écologie autoritaire on
serait presque de l'écologie totalitaire
on sait en fait que toute transition
nécessite des politiques publiques qui
soient volontariste par exemple la mise
en place d'un parc naturel ben ça c'est
la préservation de commun ce n'est pas
une privation de liberté où ils les
atteintes à la propriété privée quand on
décide en fait de faire un jardin plutôt
qu'un immeuble de 10 étages où on
s'attaque pas à la liberté de construire
non on décide c'est un changement de
batterie de préserver les communs et de
s'attaquer sérieusement à la lutte à la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
donc les promotions s'y sont pressées
pour finir vous pourrez y répond
les propositions qui sont aujourd'hui
sur la table et qui ont été reprises
notamment par exemple par la convention
sur le climat qui réunit des citoyens
des économistes des chercheurs mais
également des citoyens comme vous et moi
qui n'ont pas de compétences
particulières
il faut aujourd'hui l'unanimité sur le
transport aérien
c'est par exemple l'interdiction des
vols qui font qu'ils font moins de
quatre heures c'est la limitation
effectivement de la construction de
nouveaux aéroports est bon ça me
pardonnez moi parce que c'est vrai
oui merci beaucoup moi je vais d'abord
rendre justice aux français et à la
france
je suis totalement écologistes si
j'écris un livre là-dessus c'est le
deuxième j'en avais déjà écrit en 2014
c'est parce que je crois beaucoup à la
protection de l'environnement j'ai comme
envie de dire que la france
il faut rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar a baissé de 25% ses émissions de
co2 depuis 1990 se veut pas dire qu'il
faut qu'on arrête mais qu'il faut qu'on
continue on a les émissions de co2 par
habitant très faible plus jeune et plus
faible des grands pays du monde et ça
jamais vous ne le disait monsieur
coronado
est ce que vous n'aimez pas la france et
la france est un pays est là attendez
laissez moi finir elle les émissions de
co2 par habitant de la france sont plus
faibles que le terrien moyens c'est à
dire et ça c'est les sources de la
banque mondiale que tout le monde pourra
vérifier on est en dessous du terrien
moyens qui comprend des sud américains
qui sont plus pauvres des africains qui
sont plus pauvres et des gens en asie
donc on va pas réussir si vous voulez il
faut pas culpabiliser les français on
peut aller beaucoup plus loin il faut un
programme volontariste je suis d'accord
avec la logique du bien commun par
contre je pense que c'est dans une
écologie constructive je suis d'accord
là on est dans une écologie punitive
c'est à dire de rendre accessibles les
produits écologiques comme la voiture à
hydrogène qui a au même prix que les
voitures à essence et c'est possible il
y a juste un échec de marché il faut les
produire en grande série pour qu'elles
soient moins chers et pour le moment le
marché n'arrive pas le faire parce que
les séries sont trop petite avec une
politique volontariste en imposant aux
villes élan pour l imposer et là ça
aurait beaucoup plus de puissance
un imposant villes comme lyon bordeaux
paris dans cinq ans de n'acheter que des
voitures neuves à hydrogène pour ses
habitants
les voitures anciennes pouvant circuler
ou
c'est immédiatement une production de
série et vous réservez une grande partie
du problème des émissions de co2 de la
france
et là vous voyez ce n'est pas de la
suffisance et du volontarisme et c'est
une vision vraiment volontariste on est
train de trouver drôle en fait quand il
s'agit d'imposer l'usagé de la voiture
là c'est pas punitif et c'est pas
contraignants ont il s'agit de
promouvoir par exemple l'usagé du vélo
là c'est autoritaire c'est presque
totalitaire
enfin monsieur soyons un peu un peu
concrets les français aujourd'hui aux
consciences comme vous le dites à vous
définissez comme écolo la majorité de
nos concitoyens a conscience de la
gravité de la crise climatique et a
envie d agir parfois par des petits
gestes en consommant moins de viande de
nos végétarien en privilégiant des
transports les élections municipales et
donne un petit enseignements notamment
dans les métropoles
c'est à dire que le discours que vous
avez sur la promotion coûte que coûte de
la voiture en faisant appel à la
recherche et tout ça est relativement
cas du plus fort la jaquette et ça ne
rentre pas en fait dans la reconquête
majoritairement exprimés par nos
concitoyens de voir leur centre-ville en
fait oxygénée libérer de la place de la
voiture
il s'agit pas simplement de la question
de la pollution l'usagé de la voiture
sequana construit des villes en fait qui
était fait pour la voiture les gens ont
désormais envie d'autres types d'
espaces de vie commune
faut le comprendre c'est pas simplement
une histoire démission c'est aussi une
forme d'aménagement où on privilégie la
convivialité le contact la ring et sur
les voies de venir donner moi j'allais
moi je vais je vais citer françois
ruffin qui est à l'origine avec delphine
batho de cette proposition si vous
voulez bien m'écouter on sait que les
10% les plus riches p 4 fois moins de
taxe carbone que 10 % les plus pauvres
alors qu'ils émettent huit fois plus de
co2 il n'y aurait pas là l'art tout de
même une forme de lutte des classes dans
l'ambition écologistes avec ce genre de
proposition je pose la question sergio
coronado tout à l'heure mon
interlocuteur disait c'est une façon
très autoritaire s'attaque à la liberté
et on veut imposer le rationnement mais
le rationnement il existe il ya toute
une partie de nos concitoyens qui ne
prennent pas l'avion qui ne prendront
année l'avion c'est 10 % de la
population mondiale qui prend l'avion en
fait le rationnement il existe déjà
donc la promotion de delphine batho elle
visait à quoi enfin elle vise à
rationaliser et le dit voilà on dispose
un crédit carbone qui permet en fait de
respecter les trajectoires sur lesquels
les pays se sont engagés notamment la
france a la peau 21 et donc il permet en
fait d'avoir une égalité devant l' usage
de ce transport là qui est très polluant
et dont vous avez un crédit carbone que
vous utilisez et qu'on voulait épuiser
vous ne pouvez plus continuer à voyager
en avion et série de l'avion en tout cas
philippe maurer sur cette question est
centrale mot de la fin s'il vous plaît
et moi je compte je pense quand même
quand on parle par exemple de
l'interdiction de la voiture dans les
beaux quartiers
je veux dire c'est l'interdiction de la
voiture aux banlieusards et là ce n'est
pas dans les coeurs de paris de bordeaux
et de lyon et ça va poser un vrai
problème aux soignants ou aux caissières
de supermarché qui habitent souvent pas
paris et qui se déplace à paris pour se
déplacer c'est loin d'être simple et
évident et elles vont pas prendre le
vélo pour faire 30 km tous les matins
forcément toutes les personnes diront et
sur l'avion sur sur la réponse sur
l'avion je pense que c'est une réponse
qui concerne 3 % des émissions de co2 de
la france que ces faibles et qui
voudrait beaucoup mieux aller vers
d'avion hydrogène on peut le faire dans
quinze ans sans embêter tout le monde
sans vos tickets de rationnement que
vous proposez j'en suis désolé je trouve
moi ce n'est pas la vision de l'écologie
qui intéresse les français c'est là la
écologie punitive justement qu'il
rejette 1.1 point simplement parce qu'on
arrive à la moi je suis en user comme
vous dites avec beaucoup de mépris et
les banlieusards monsieur ils prennent
les transports en commun et en ferait le
mieux de rénover ses transports en
commun parce que c'est une vue de
l'esprit penser des banlieusards
arrivent tous à paris en voiture
bon merci à tous les deux en même temps
vous invitez parce que vous n'étiez pas
d'accord alors voila merci philippe
sergio coronado d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france aime bien ça se
finit avec deux sourires je suis
contente
ce jeudi la justice a reconnu la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
le scandale de la dea paquin le pays est
condamné à indemniser trois familles
dont les enfants sont lourdement
handicapée à cause de ce médicament
le laboratoire sanofi et des médecins
prescripteurs sont aussi jugés
responsables
elana ferradj ans après plus de quatre
ans d'enquêté
le couperet est tombé l'état est bien
responsable dans le scandale de la dea
paquin un puissant anti épileptiques
prescrit à des milliers de femmes dès
les années 80 dont 10000 entre 2007 et
2014 malformations du visage retard de
développement troubles autistiques
strabisme le médicament prescrit aux
personnes souffrant de troubles
bipolaires est à l'origine d'un risque
élevé d'anomalies congénitales sur le
foetus
pour la première fois la justice se
prononce et donc sur les requêtes
administratif déposé par trois familles
dont les enfants âgés de 11 à 35 ans
sont aujourd'hui lourdement handicapé
un véritable combat comme le raconte
marine martin mère de deux enfants
handicapés à cause du débat qui n'a tous
les jours des enfants est soudé paquin
toi tu sais tu dis rien c'est
non-assistance à personne en danger et
c'est comme ça que j'ai décidé de
dénoncer le scandale sanitaire de fonder
une association pour trouver d'autres
mamans dans le même cas que moi et de
faire éclater le scandale au grand chose
finalement m'avez menti on m'avait
trompé qu'on continue à tromper les
femmes épileptiques en leur faisant
croire que le médicament qu'elle prenait
quotidiennement était sans risque pour
le bébé et donc il fallait que je
dénonce ce scandale
sanitaire parce que le garder pour moi
ça m'aurait détruire ce jeudi l'état a
donc été condamné à indemniser chaque
famille à des montants d'environ 200000
euros
290 1000 euros et vingt mille euros en
fonction de la date de naissance des
enfants concernés mais ces familles ne
sont pas les seuls l'ad-pa qui
naissaient dérivés aurait provoqué
depuis la fin des années 1960 des
malformations congénitales graves chez
2150 à 4100 enfants selon une évaluation
de l'agencé nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé et
de l'assurance maladie
la molécule en cause le valproate de
sodium
commercialisé depuis 1967 sous la marque
des paquin par le laboratoire sanofi
après quarante deux plaintes de familles
et une vingtaine de procédures
judiciaires
le laboratoire a été mis en examen en
février pour tromperie aggravée et
blessures involontaires
aujourd'hui la justice reconnaît donc sa
part de responsabilité tout comme celle
de l'état qui a failli à son devoir
d'action et d'information
de son côté sanofi a nié tout acte
répréhensible disant qu'il avait averti
les autorités sanitaires des risques du
médicament dès les années 1980 un
scandale qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui du médiator
si un procès historique est en cours
depuis septembre une décision est
attendue dans le courant du mois la
crise eût commis 19 a suscité beaucoup
polémique parmi elles la protection de
nos données par y en a en effet lancé le
el sadate arabe une plate forme de mise
à disposition des données de santé
visant à améliorer la qualité des soins
cela devait être gérée par microsoft un
choix très critiqué une demande
d'enquêté parlementaire a même été
déposé la france va donc lancer un appel
d'offres pour remplacer le géant
américain thomas bonnet vous ne le
saviez peut-être pas mais un nombre
incalculable de nos données médicales
sont désormais centralisées hébergés sur
un système de cloud dans le cadre du
projet elfe data m lancé officiellement
le
remy décembre dernier par agnès buzyn il
a été décidé de regrouper ces données
sensibles afin de les analyser et
d'améliorer la qualité des soins
l'intelligence artificielle au service
de la santé c'est une évolution qui fait
débat mais ce n'est pas ici le coeur du
problème le souci principal de cette
innovation française
c'est le choix de la société pour
héberger ces données c'est l'offre de
cloud azure produite par microsoft qui a
été sélectionné par le gouvernement un
choix problématique pour beaucoup
d'acteurs du secteur microsoft est en
effet soumis au cloud act une loi
américaine qui contraint les entreprises
situées aux états unis à transmettre les
informations stockées sur leur serveur
sur demande des autorités américaines
ainsi les données des millions de
patients en france est jugée comme
stratégiques pourraient potentiellement
se retrouver entre les mains des
services américains de quoi provoquer
l'inquiétude d'un certain nombre de
médecins français dont certains ont
signé cette tribune parue dans le monde
et intitulé l'exploitation de données de
santé sur une plateforme de microsoft
exposé à des risques multiples
concrètement les patients pourraient
être soumis à une rupture du secret
médical
ce qui constitue en danger aussi
personnelle que symbolique
l'intégrité du serment d'hippocrate
étant remises en cause inquiétudes
soulevées aussi dès janvier 2018 par le
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
qui évoquait déjà la notion de
souveraineté
mettant en avant la nécessité d'une
implantation française et européenne de
ses infrastructures
idem du côté de la cnil qui préconise un
hébergement des données réservé à des
entités relevant exclusivement des
juridictions de l'union européenne un
message pas vraiment pris en
considération lorsqu'il a fallu choisir
une entreprise pour le lte data web
les initiateurs du projet justifie ce
choix par une volonté de concrétisation
la plus simple et la plus rapide
possible
un choix très critiqué donc tant la
politique dégâts femmes en matière de
protection des données et controversé
d'ailleurs même edouard snowdon s'est
ému de ce partenariat du goût
vernement français avec ceux qu'il
qualifie de cartel du cloud médecin
physiciens ou encore expert en
informatique alerte sur les dérives
potentielles de la gestion par microsoft
de nos données médicales face à toutes
ces critiques et à différents recours
déposés par les opposants au projet le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique a
finalement annoncé la semaine dernière
le lancement d'un appel d'offres
il serait normal que dans les mois à
venir nous puissions lancer un appel
d'offres afin d'avoir un choix plus
large avec les spécifications qui
permettront à quelqu'un de se
positionner
cela permettra peut-être de trouver un
hébergeur européen même si l'implication
de microsoft dans l'élaboration du
projet rendrait la transition quelque
peu délicate
cette affaire pose une nouvelle fois
l'épineuse question de la souveraineté
numérique car si le principe de
souveraineté est à la mode notamment
dans les propos d' emmanuel macron ces
derniers mois il est décidément
compliquée avec cette notion de passer
de la théorie à la pratique
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire entrées en france le
24 mars dernier le parlement doit
dévoiler les grandes lignes pour une
sortie prévue le 11 juillet prochain et
puis direction la côte d'ivoire où
l'ancien président henri konan bédié
sera candidat aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
[Musique]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qui est un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse est fort dans
mondial on essaie le faire perdurer mais
on est à la fin d'un modèle qui était le
tout misé sur la dette la dette et la
relance par la dette ou par la création
monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est en imprimant des billets
que pour relancer une économie si on
essaie autant de relancer la croissance
économique s'est pas fondamentalement on
sait on sait pas faire sans pas censé
connaître je peux pas continuer à
diffuser des chiffres qui sont
absolument faux simplement parce que ça
arrange monsieur trump à ce moment là
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france le parlement doit adopter
définitivement ce soir le projet de loi
sur la sortie l'état d'urgence sanitaire
du pro 11 juillet ultime vote de
l'assemblée nationale dans la soirée qui
vaudra adoption définitive
de son côté le sénat à rocher texte ce
matin si l'hexagone doit sortir de
l'état d'urgence il devrait en revanche
elle prolongé jusqu'au 30 octobre inclus
en guyane et à mayotte où le virus
continue de circuler activement elle
nous retrouvons un autre reporter à
guémar aussi devant l'allée l'hémicycle
bonsoir guillemin c'est le dernier round
en cas d'un fast ont parlementaire qui
dure maintenant depuis plus de trois
semaines
et oui bonsoir stéphanie oui comme vous
l'avez dit donc un dernier acte qui doit
mettre fin à cet état d'urgence
sanitaire donc entrer en vigueur vous
l'avez dit le 24 mars dernier alors ce
texte comme vous l'imaginez bien il
divise
parmi les députés mais il rencontre
également une très forte opposition
parmi les sénateurs vous l'avez dit le
sénat a rejeté ce matin
ce texte alors qu'est ce que reproche la
chambre haute à ce texte
eh bien ils reprochent de prétendre
mettre fin à cet état d'urgence
sanitaire tout en conservant la
possibilité de restreindre certaines
libertés comme par exemple la liberté de
circuler la liberté d'accueillir du
public dans certains établissements ou
encore la liberté de se rassembler et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a annoncé le
sénateur philippe bas
à l'issue du de cette séance du sénat le
seul filet bas le président de la
commission des lois du sénat il a
déclaré que le gouvernement voulait je
cite conserver les moyens de l'état
d'urgence sans le dire est que les
citoyens avaient davantage besoin de
vérité et de responsabilité que de
risquer une forme d'infantilisation et
parmi les députés ici opposé à ce texte
et ils sont très nombreux le constat est
similaire écoutez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on nous maintient dans un
d'urgence sanitaire un état d'urgence
sanitaire pardon
expliquez-moi les français on leur a
demandé d'aller voter et français ont
quasiment leur quotidien alors mis les
gestes barrière
fonctionne et on leur dit qu'on est
toujours en état d'urgence sanitaire
il ya d'autres outils qui sont
disponibles pour l'exécutif que de
maintenir en état d'urgence était
l'urgence on a enfin des habitués mais
il ya cinq ans
poète français savez ce que ça veut dire
état d'urgence à remonter aux années 60
la précédente
donc attention aux privations de liberté
alors c'est donc à la chambre basse que
revient le dernier mot comme le prévoit
à nouveau institutions alors malgré
l'opposition de nombreux députés il ne
devrait pas y avoir beaucoup de suspense
ici ou palais bourbon car si le
gouvernement a perdu stricto sensu sa
majorité parlementaire il devrait
pouvoir compter sur les voix de nombreux
députés centristes et donc voir adopter
cette sortie de l'état d'urgence une
sortie en trompe l'oeil comme l'a
qualifiée le sénat merci gaymard aussi
et pour en parler
elle nous sommes avec francis choisel
historien spécialiste de la constitution
de la vème république bonsoir parce
qu'il se faisait merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors voilà
petit rappel de constitution le texte a
de l'argent chances d'être adopté un
dans un hémicycle
quand même majorité présidentielle alors
que le sénat l'a rejeté pas plus tard
que ce matin
oui est il dès lors que l'assemblée
adopte le texte le sénat ne peut plus
rien faire dans les républiques
précédentes
il fallait un accord entre l'assemblée
qui s'appelait chambre des députés sur
la troisième république et le sénat pour
qu'un texte passe sous notre
constitution
après une navette entre le sénat et
l'assemblée la santé l'assemblée peut
avoir le dernier mot
dès lors que le gouvernement l'a décidé
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
alors on entend effectivement ces
députés qui sont peu content ce qui est
en jeu pour eux c'est un texte jugé
lippert liberticide
c'est l'avis du constitutionnaliste que
vous êtes également
il est évident que dans la mesure où la
vie reprend le où semble-t-il la
lipidémie le terminer il n'y a aucune
raison de restreindre les libertés ou
plus exactement il n'y a aucune règle en
de prévoir à l'avancement dans un club
on doit en quelque sorte le restera ses
libertés
on pourrait très bien imaginer s'il
n'est qu' demir partait que le
parlement soit convoqué pour autoriser
le gouvernement à prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles
mais là dans la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons on doit au poil
jusqu'au 30 octobre
le gouvernement a carte blanche pour
mettre entre parenthèses la liberté de
circulation la liberté de réunion et la
liberté de manifestation s'attendre
france et choisel à ce que le conseil
d'état jouent un rôle on a vu qu'il
avait été saisi plusieurs fois et que
parfois les requérants avaient eu gain
de cause est ce que sur ce plan il ya
cette dernière juridiction qui peut
faire recours
non parce que le conseil d'état elle
intervient avant le vote de la loi celui
qui va intervenir ou comme on peut le
voir ce sera le conseil constitutionnel
car l'opposition peut saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur la constitutionalité
ce territoire même le président du sénat
tout seul a la possibilité de ces de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
puisque le sénat dans sa majorité a voté
contre cette loi
il est fort possible que gérard larcher
décide tout seul mais au nom du sénat de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
il est possible aussi que le président
de la république et saisisse le conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi non pas parce
qu'il est opposé à la loi mais parce que
si c'est lui qui saisit pour ces
constitutionnel et que le conseil
constitutionnel sanctionne la loi ça ne
sera pas une victoire pour l'opposition
ce sera mis au crédit du président de la
république qui a pris toutes les
précautions démocratique pour le faire
et puis enfin si le n'y a ni l'autre ne
saisisse le conseil constitutionnel
soixante sénateurs ou 60 députés peuvent
saisir le conseil constitutionnel c'est
prévu par la constitution
pour qu'une minorité puisse saisir le
conseil constitutionnel donc même à
l'assemblée où l'opposition est
minoritaire
soixante députés c'est peu par rapport à
aux noms aux chiffres du nombre de
députés d'opposition 60 députés peuvent
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
alors le président d'acs
mission des lois de la chambre haute un
gamin aussi le disait dit avoir
l'impression que le gouvernement veut
conserver les moyens de l'état d'urgence
sans le dire et il plein nos concitoyens
en plus besoin de vérité de
responsabilité que de risquer une forme
d'infantilisation est ce qu'on est
on en est là à conserver les moyens
d'état d'urgence sans le dire ça veut
dire qu'à une forme de tromperie en tout
cas de la part de l'opinion veut
philippe bas si ta posture apportez
votre journaliste moi bonjour trois
pôles terme d'infantilisation certes
dans toute cette crise et même en dehors
de cette crise
on a tendance tous gouvernements
confondus depuis quelques années avant
qu'ils lisent et les français mais je
trouve que c'est assez faible là on est
dans une atteinte aux libertés
je le répète que ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est une carte blanche au
gouvernement s'était d'instruction des
pouvoirs extraordinaires pour que le
gouvernant par simple décret c'est
d'ailleurs sans consultation du
parlement ou même un préfet dans un dans
un département puissent prendre des
mesures qui empêchent n'importe quel
citoyen de se déplacer correctement de
se réunir
ajoutez à cela que le gouvernement a non
annoncé qu'il reprenait un certain
nombre de réformes
il a annoncé qu'il voulait reprendre les
réformes
la réforme des retraites donc le
gouvernement pourra interdire des
réunions qui seront faites dans des
salles contre la réforme des retraites
pour interdire des manifestations alors
on entendait un député d'ille il ya
d'autres outils disponibles alors la vie
justement du spécialiste de la
constitution y at il d'autres ont pied
indisponible pour pour aboutir à
l'équivalent de l'état sanitaire de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le droit de le droit manifestation
qu'elle comment fonctionne ne le droit
de manifestation dans le système actuel
par l'actuel ses dialogues dont le dal
dans la règle normale on déclare on va
faire une manifestation et on l'a fait
mais mais le gouvernement a la
possibilité de l'interdire mais là on a
inversé les choses il faut demander
l'autorisation
donc voyez même dans le système normal
le gouvernement peut être interdit
une manifestation moi j'ai eu l'occasion
personnellement dans un cadre politique
d'organiser des manifestations
et bien il y a eu un contact avant la
manifestation pour voir comment ça
allait se passer
et puis la manifestation a été autorisée
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que même
dans le cadre actuel le gouvernement
dispose de la possibilité d'interdire à
titre exceptionnel une manifestation
merci francis loisel d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur tesfran rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste de la constitution
de la vème république merci à vous à 86
ans henri konan-bédié accepté le 20 juin
dernier d'être le candidat du parti
démocratique de côte d'ivoire à
l'élection présidentielle ivoirienne du
31 octobre 2020 si la polémique autour
de son âge a suscité de vives réactions
il est pour certains un candidat
légitime les explications de claire
gecko le sphinx de daoukro n'a jamais
aussi bien porté son nom
henri konan-bédié est loin d'être un
inconnu dans le paysage politique
ivoirien président du pays entre 1993 et
1999 il a été renversé suite à un coup
d'état militaire
en 2010 il décide de se représenter
il arrive en troisième position à
l'issue du premier tour derrière laurent
gbagbo et alassane ouattara
cinq ans plus tard en 2015 il annonce
rallier la candidature d'alassane
ouattara et ne présente pas de candidat
au parti démocratique de côte d'ivoire
à 86 ans il revient donc sur le devant
de la scène en tant que candidat du pdc
y une candidature qui nourrit la
polémique auprès de la jeunesse
ivoirienne
la passe d'achever d'un riz qu'on avait
diakhaté b 6
m il est âgé donc ce préfet qui se
repose enfin qu'il faut bien que
quelqu'un d'autre qui va du découvert
conseiller prud'homme laisser le pouvoir
à la jeunesse pour que vous moi le
pouvoir régional à juliette parce que la
puberté voilà qu'elle former des jeunes
est la meilleure de la pop laisse voir
est jeune et je crois qu'un amuse jeunes
on pourrait en premier lieu samedi la
solution est en tout cas non je pense
que henry qu'on habite et devait laisser
la place à la jeunesse
si la ghana du président henri konan
bédié
après six ans vraiment c'est pas du tout
moi j'ai peint en rose et noir normal
qui va c'est le blues ils ont mieux nous
en porter euros auparavant l'âge limite
pour être candidat à la présidentielle
en côte d'ivoire était fixé à 75 ans une
restriction qui éliminé d'office
l'octogénaire mais en 2016 la
constitution est modifiée et l'âge
limite est levée la scène dispositions
constitutionnelles relativement à la
conditionnalité de l'âge pour être
président de la république fixait la de
l'âge limite à 75 ans est évidemment
monsieur laurent gbagbo monsieur
alassane ouattra mso bidi d'un telle
posture c'est vrai
inapte à briguer la présidence de la
république la réforme en étant
intervenue l'âge limite a été sautée
aujourd'hui maison dans un système de
plus en plus libérale relativement à
cette conditionnalité et donc toute
personne en côte d'ivoire ayant plus de
35 ans peut valablement vouloir briguer
la présidence de la république
un âge qui ne fait en tout cas pas débat
au sein du pdc y comme en témoigne jean
louis billon secrétaire exécutif du
parti vous savez le président bédié
c'est vrai il a un certain âge nous
l'appelons le vieux mais il est le seul
vieux dans l'équipe
l'équipe même et je ne voudrais que la
moyenne d'âge des cadres le pdci est
plus jeune que celle les autres partis
aujourd'hui l'âge du président bédié
c'est vrai est un âge avancé il a une
expérience il a connu plusieurs crises
dans le pays et il a su s'entourer de
cadres jeunes dynamiques et compétents
c'est surtout cela qui trouvera les les
électeurs vers en une équipe en face
d'eux ils verront des jeunes débattre
ils verront des compétences diverses et
variées en face d'eux et c'est ça le
plus important
henri konan-bédié a donc désormais
quatre mois de campagne électorale
devant lui pour tenter de convaincre le
peuple ivoirien qui se rendra aux urnes
le 31 octobre prochain
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec les mangas au journaliste et
directeur du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui
bonsoir tellement hier vers 6 d'être
avec nous alors plus de vingt ans après
la fin de son mandat cette candidature
du président ex président bédié ce
qu'elle a créé la surprise en côte
d'ivoire disons que c'est vrai bébé
après leurs ergots la bd reste encore
dans les yeux pour le titre puisque
l'été quand dix candidats en 2010 c'est
le cas de michael a appelé ses partisans
à voter alassane ouattara mais vu la
composition politique la côte d'ivoire
et quand on voit encore la moyenne d'âge
alcoa bedia 4 6 ans et alassane ouattra
elana 78 euros gbagbo soit 115
génération qui est en train
deux ministres des combats et quoique
janvier en s'éjectant dans cette course
à la présidentielle de 2000 jean quoi
réellement en ses chances
il pense que il a certainement ils ont
un certain nombre de rattraper puisque
lui-même l'a reconnu que la commune
c'est notre politique à force politique
est vraiment personnel alors pour lui
c'est le combat dès 2020 ce sera
l'occasion pour lui de réparer un peu
tout ce qu'il a pu commettre comme aussi
et amener la cua d'ivoire c'est le
conseiller s'est un peu les lettres
mythiques été lancée au c17 nouvelle
coalition qui la voirie ça c'est pour la
version officielle mais enfin on peut
décemment se poser la question qu'est ce
qui pousse à un homme de 86 ans puis qui
pourrait un petit peu se reposer
peut-être à briguer la présidence est ce
que c'est une histoire de vengeance de
revanche plutôt on se souvient qu'il
avait été recherchée du pouvoir par un
putsch mes souvenirs sont bons
oui tout à fait oui c'est effectivement
c'est vrai que à 86 ans vient parce que
en colombie des actes et l'ajout dé plus
en possession de ses capacités mais on
l'a vu à mettre des paysans de cette
invention
en afrique on habitait encore toute sa
tête et puis il faut considérer aussi
l'aspect au rallye culturel et même
traditionnels d'afrique
4 à 6 ans est chez nous on oublie que le
vieux c'est un peu les sages
c'est un peu celui qu'un canapé toute la
sagesse celui qui est à même de pouvoir
prend les décisions a beaucoup de
beaucoup avec cette capacité dans
l'analyse alors à cet âge là on estime
que le gia ou le vieux con c'est le
contraste comme vieillards et est à même
de pouvoir prendre des décisions lucides
alors c'est un peu tous ses aspects
l'idée traditionnelle et anthropologique
qui pèse à peine sa faveur donc c'est
qu'au niveau du pdc y est la jna parce
que jamais comptés on a vu au temps du
président houphouët boigny l'avait cet
âge mais bon et à chaque fois il était
candidat unique et candidat naturel du
pdc c'est cette tradition qui veulent la
cultiver au sein de son parti et
l'hépatite de harnes en comparaison en
bédié alors on l'a souvent présenté
comme l'homme je suis de
voirie t est-ce qu'il a changé écoutez
de toutes les façons il a eu nettement
il ya il a quand même content lui ce
concept d'ivoirité qui se vend lui et
ses partisans auraient été galvaudé à
l'origine un concept culturel qui
définit un peu l'ivoirien qui disent
transmis l'ivoirien les autres
communautés africaines alors mais
maintenant que nous avons arrêté un
aspect politique au social
cela a apaisé vraiment à sa défaveur on
dit que aujourd'hui à la bd est un
caraco l'ivoirité bon écoutez c'est pas
moi du fait ce commentaire on l'a vu nom
décédée n'est sorti la portée du bois
les étrangers qui le peut dans les mines
ont exploité de façon au mali
traditionnelle et ces personnes est
parti trois comme états étrangers qui
pourraient bien ces personnes à
reconduire cette nombre de troubles dans
ces régions où l on est exploité voilà
donc l'ivoirité c'est vrai c'est ce
concept aujourd'hui il encore
d'actualité et il n'est vraiment pas à
la faveur de l'économie tisse alors
quelle politique internationale
pourrait-il mener mais je pense que
c'est quand même personnalité qui a eu à
diriger la côte d'ivoire
et pendant son 4 4 années voire cinq
années avant le coup 19 essais qui y ont
habité tout ça ne pourra pas diriger la
côte d'ivoire
et comme j'ai des souvenirs tout à
l'heure vers coalition qui a été mise en
place en juillet et leurs angoisses et
les un accord et cet accord est assorti
d'un projet politique qui est qui
s'appelle le comité national paritaire
de collaboration entre les deux parties
alors s'est dit que si le cabinet
médiéval a gagné ces élections qui est
lourd à gouverner la côte d'ivoire avec
les autres donc au plan international il
va forcément les ordres qui sont en
capacité dont ceux qui défendent la côte
d'ivoire le modèle était dans sa nasse
merci beaucoup clément yao d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle vous êtes
journaliste et directeur du magazine
l'afrique
aujourd'hui merci à vous et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci d'avoir suivi on
se retrouve à 22 heures pile pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone azithromycine malgré
la polémique mondiale sur l'efficacité
de cette combinaison là le porte parole
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les boutiques leur équipe
bien avant que le match ne commence en
effet par sénégal la chloroquine de
manière à les utiliser pendant des
décennies et des décennies sa femme un
père sourire
les sénégalais quand j'entends devenu
gênant il n'y a pas de signes qui m'est
rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
en pleine crise du couronne virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus et dante crise la
montée en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et romont la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
de bien choisir
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 black sun araw
ni la gravité lada pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie et pour le développement
global car nous avons besoin aussi
d'être en paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
sécheresse mauvaises récoltes canicule
il y avait beaucoup de bétail avant
aujourd'hui il est impossible d'avoir
des animaux
rien ne pousse ici que mangerait les
animaux le climat de la terre est
aujourd'hui plus chaud qui ne l'a été au
cours des cent mille dernières années
[Musique]
padoue pour la maison pas d'eau pour
cela vaut à la fin du siècle
il fera encore plus chaud
le moment est venu de réfléchir à la
façon d'en gérer les conséquences
comment nous sauver cela entraînera
d'importants bouleversements à quel
impact faut-il s'attendre
seront ils visible dans l'environnement
l'économie et la politique
personne ne le sait pour liste tous les
secteurs de la culture sont sont touchés
la musique le cinéma le théâtre elle les
musées avec trois mois de nos activités
ou les billetteries sont à l'arrêt
l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera un redémarrage sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des fluxs
que nous attendons c'est effectivement
la possibilité de rouvrir sans ces
mesures barrières le plus vite possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché se
reprendre à plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans sa
cuisine des bâches me suis aperçu que
c'était bien que difficiles qui avait
une équipe de vaccins cuisinier au tour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
groupe d'avants il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver je pensais
que ça allait me rendre plus tolérante
ça m'a rendu plus intolérante alors
parfois elle c'est vrai vous posez
justement délirer autour d'un dessert
que j'ai appelé la pêche la bac
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
base arm à l'hôpital martin hirsch le
patron de l'ap-hp accuse de professeurs
out de faux témoignages en peau de
déclarations du médecin marseillais lors
de son audition par la commission
denquête sur le comique 19 une sur le
nombre de morts à paris d'autres sur
l'hospitalisation dès le mois de janvier
d'impression chinois le coup au volant
forte en russie les électeurs ont validé
la réforme constitutionnelle à près de
78%
une victoire pour vladimir poutine le
dirigeant russe a remercié les citoyens
cette réforme lui permettra de se
représenter encore deux fois à
l'élection présidentielle l'opposition
dénonce des irrégularités les courses et
danser en côte d'ivoire le pays a
clôturé ces listes électorales ce mardi
à quatre mois de la présidentielle une
question est dans tous les esprits
qui succédera à alassane ouattara au
pouvoir depuis dix ans parmi les
candidats l'ancien président bédié
du parti démocratique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france didier
rahout attaqué de toutes parts après son
audition devant la commission denquête
de l'assemblée nationale le 24 juin le
professeur marseillais est accusée de
mensonge par martin hirsch directeur de
l'ap-hp mais aussi par le conseil
scientifique et la haute autorité de
santé
les détails en son et en image
il me semble essentiel que les travaux
de la commission ne puisse être fondé
sur des éléments factuels m'en faut et
que les suites qui s'imposent puisse
être donnée
la mortalité dans les réanimations ici à
paris dans ce travail toujours est de
43% chez nous à marseille
elle est de 16% nous n'avons aucune
donnée qui place à 43 % la mortalité
dans les réanimations de l'ap-hp d'autre
part il n'y a à ce jour aucune étude
publiée qui analysent comparativement
les taux de mortalité en réanimation
évalué dans des conditions contrôlées
entre les hôpitaux parisiens et
marseillais
le patient chinois de 80 ans s'est
présenté à la pitié salpêtrière il est
rentré chez lui il revenu sept jours
après elle est venue mourir dans un
hôpital
le seul patient chinois de 80 ans auquel
peut faire référence le professeur
didier raoul tu as été admis le 25
janvier 2020 à l'hôpital européen
georges pompidou il n'a jamais été
renvoyé chez lui
[Musique]
la rigueur scientifique l'indépendance
et transparence sont les valeurs de
l'institution que je préside
je ne saurais accepter que la réputation
de la haute autorité de santé
son sérieux et son intégrité soit remis
en cause
pour violaine guérin médecin
immunologiste on big trop de log et
philippe froguel chercheur en doctrine
hologue également biologie moléculaire
et génétique les accusations dont est
victime didier rahout ne sont pas
justifiées nous avons tous entendu les
témoignages à la télévision de madame
lacombe de monsieur comme et de
différentes personnes en plein milieu de
la crise où effectivement ces chiffres
et est annoncé donc ce sont quand même
des gens qui travaillent à l'assistance
publique de paris qui ont donc a priori
dit des choses exactes
et puis d'autre part bon on sait qu'en
général monsieur raoul tu document
plutôt assez bien ce qu'il raconte
je pense que vu l'état actuel de la
crise quand on prend des positions on
fait ce type d'assertion sait de quoi
l'on parle en général ces deux
informations ont bien été donnée à la
fin du mois de janvier elles sont
peut-être fausse mais c'est pas du faux
témoignage
si ces gens se sont trompés à ce moment
là bas vous s'est trompé bon il a le
droit de se tromper mais ce qu'il a dit
a bien été annoncée il ya énormément de
conflit d'intérêts et c'est pas
seulement au niveau français qu'il faut
le regarder je pense que c'est une
problématique mondiale qu'il faut
détricoter il y a des choses totalement
anormal pour la première fois de ma vie
j'ai été menacé parce que je publiais un
article beaucoup de médecins voir la
plupart des médecins ce qu'on appelle
les leaders d'opinion ont des relations
avec les industriels du médicament est
donc effectivement là une très grande
part des gentils semences et commuter en
on avoir des relations avec des
industriels ne veut pas dire d'avoir des
conflits d'intérêts ou plus exactement
avoir des conflits potentiels et ça veut
pas dire qu'ils sont vendus à ces
industriels
le parlement doit adopter définitivement
ce soir le projet de loi sur la sortie
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire du 11
juillet ultime vote de l'assemblée
nationale dans la soirée et qui vaudra
adoption définitive
de son côté le sénat a rejeté le texte
ce matin 6
hexagone doit sortir de l'état d'urgence
il devrait en revanche être prolongé
jusqu'au 30 octobre inclus en guyane et
à mayotte où le virus continue de sévir
selon francis choisel historien
spécialiste de la constitution de la
vème république il existe une forme un
contenant compréhension autour de la
restriction
il est évident que dans la mesure où
quittent la vie reprend le haut où
semble-t-il là l'épidémie est terminée
il n'y a aucune raison de restreindre
les libertés ou plus exactement il n'y a
aucune règle en de prévoir à l'avant ce
que le gouvernement dans un club on doit
en quelque sorte le restera ses libertés
on pourrait très bien imaginer s'il
n'est qu' demir par terre que le
parlement soit convoqué pour autoriser
le gouvernement à prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles
mais là dans la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons on doit parfois
jusqu'au 30 octobre
le gouvernement a carte blanche pour
mettre entre parenthèses la liberté de
circulation la liberté de réunion et la
liberté de manifestation
c'est une méthode qui relance la
polémique sur la pma la technique font
pas a été adopté par les députés de la
commission spéciale bioéthique
qualifiait aussi de maternité partager
elle s'adresse aux couples de femmes
elle consiste à inséminer l'ovocyte
féconder d'une des femmes dans l'utérus
de l'autre si en octobre 2019 lors des
premiers votes sur la question le
verdict avait été défavorable à
l'adoption de l'amendement
cette fois il est bien entré dans la loi
mais certains députés ont dénoncé une
pratique trop proche de la gestion par
commission spéciale pour le projet de
loi bioéthique à l'assemblée nationale
constant lucide et tant décrié le parti
chrétien démocrate n'a cessé d'alerter
sur l'étape d'après contenus dans
chacune des évolutions dit de progrès
ivg pacs pma et maintenant avec rot
passé la gpa
oui l'homme est en péril interdire à une
femme de faire don de ses ovocytes à sa
partenaire et à cette dernière dans
portait l'embryon n'est rien d'autre que
du paternalisme de mauvais aloi cette
méthode permet de maximiser les
réussites d'une fiv et doit être
autorisée
la majorité vient d'adopter un
amendement d'une gravité extrême car il
ouvre subrepticement la porte à la
légalisation de la gpa
nous combattrons fermement contre intel
funeste projet est donc une forme de gpa
vient d'être votée menteur la république
en marché ce gouvernement non madame
agnès steve cet amendement ne permet en
aucun cas l'ouverture de la gpa l'arpa
permet uniquement à une femme de porter
long brion de sa compagne tout comme
pour les couples hétéros quand on
prélève les spermatozoïdes pour procéder
à une fiv dont bénéficiera les pouces et
pour allier style à député de l'oise
groupe udi indépendant le sujet de la
bioéthique en sortie de crise sanitaire
était loin d'être la priorité dit que
c'est absolument scandaleux vraiment
scandale et c'est une loi qui remet en
cause tout le droit de la filiation qui
va permettre des enfants sans père n'est
ce pas qui change tout signé des au
logis l'heureux leur idéologie ça leur
plaît pas mais c'est la suivante ce
qu'il considère que le père est une
fonction c'est à dire que ça peut être
assumée par n'importe quelle personne
une voisine un voisin un nom qu'une
grand mère que sais-je
or nous considérons que le permet pas
une fonction que le père est un homme au
niveau de la pma ou en tant que
législateur nous allons faire venir
sciemment des enfants orphelins de terre
tout de même est ce que c'est notre rôle
ça pose de graves questions est-ce qu'on
est là pour satisfaire les désirs
personnels ou pour légiférer pour un
corps social parce qu'à force de
satisfaire les désirs personnels
c'est la loi du plus fort chacun tire de
son côté nous nous sommes en train de
deux dvi
et au niveau législatif pour satisfaire
une poignée d'individus se cette fête
cet individualisme ne conduira à des
endroits où on ne veut pas aller mais
c'est scandaleux aucun membre du
gouvernement en ce moment la priorité
après cette grosse crise ducobu devra
être l'emploi devrait être l'économie et
pas du tout la bioéthique
aujourd'hui la justice a reconnu la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
le scandale de la dea paquin le pays est
condamné à indemniser trois familles
dont les enfants sont lourdement
handicapée à cause de ce médicament
le laboratoire sanofi et des médecins
prescripteurs sont aussi jugés et
responsable elana fer indiens après plus
de quatre ans d'enquêté
le couperet est tombé l'état est bien
responsable dans le scandale de la dea
paquin un puissant anti épileptiques
prescrit à des milliers de femmes dès
les années 80 dont 10000 entre 2007 et
2014 malformations du visage retard de
développement troubles autistiques
strabisme le médicament prescrit aux
personnes souffrant de troubles
bipolaires est à l'origine d'un risque
élevé d'anomalies congénitales sur le
foetus
pour la première fois la justice se
prononce et donc sur les requêtes
administratif déposé par trois familles
dont les enfants âgés de 11 à 35 ans
sont aujourd'hui lourdement handicapé
un véritable combat comme le raconte
marine martin mère de deux enfants
handicapés à cause du débat qui n'a tous
les jours des enfants en est soudé
paquin toi tu sais tu dis rien c'est
non-assistance à personne en danger et
c'est comme ça que j'ai décidé de
dénoncer le scandale sanitaire de fonder
une association pour trouver d'autres
mamans dans le même cas que moi et de
faire éclater le scandale au grand chose
finalement m'avez menti on m'avait
trompé qu'on continue à tromper les
femmes épileptiques en leur faisant
croire que le médicament qu'elle prenait
quotidiennement était sans risque pour
le bébé et donc il fallait que je
dénonce ce scandale
sanitaire parce que le garder pour moi
ça m'aurait détruit ce jeudi l'état a
donc été condamné à indemniser chaque
famille à des montants d'environ 200000
euros
290 1000 euros et vingt mille euros en
fonction de la date de naissance des
enfants concernés mais ces familles ne
sont pas les seuls la dea paquin et ses
dérivés aurait provoqué depuis la fin
des années 1960 des malformations
congénitales graves chez 2150 à 4100
enfants selon une évaluation de l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé et de l'assurance
maladie
la molécule en cause le valproate de
sodium
commercialisé depuis 1967 sous la marque
des paquin par le laboratoire sanofi
après quarante deux plaintes de familles
et une vingtaine de procédures
judiciaires
le laboratoire a été mis en examen en
février pour tromperie aggravée et
blessures involontaires
aujourd'hui la justice reconnaît donc sa
part de responsabilité tout comme celle
de l'état qui a failli à son devoir
d'action et d'information
de son côté sanofi a nié tout acte
répréhensible disant qu'il avait averti
les autorités sanitaires des risques du
médicament dès les années 1980 un
scandale qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui du médiator si un procès
historique est en cours depuis septembre
une décision est attendue dans le
courant du mois
la france condamné par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme la
juridiction de strasbourg estime que
paris a manqué à ses obligations en
laissant à la rue plusieurs demandeurs
d'asile dans des conditions je cite
inhumaines et dégradantes
il s'agissait en l'occurrence d'un
afghan d'un russe et d'un iranien âgé de
27 33 et 46 ans la cour a loué de 10000
à 12000 euros à ses trois requérants
c'est le quatrième la quatrième fois que
cette cour condamne la france en moins
d'un mois écouter le jugement
à ce cours les autorités françaises ont
manqué à leurs obligations
elles doivent être tenus pour
responsables des conditions dans
lesquelles les requérants se sont
trouvés pendant des mois vivent dans la
rue sans ressources sans accès à des
sanitaires ne disposons d'aucun moyen de
subvenir à leurs besoins essentiels et
dans l' angoisse permanente d'être
attaqué et volé le kremlin se félicite
d'un triomphe à près de 78% les russes
se sont largement prononcés en faveur de
la réforme constitutionnelle voulue par
vladimir poutine
il s'est achevé hier au terme d'une
consultation populaire étalée sur une
semaine pour éviter une trop forte
affluence dans les bureaux de vote le
président russe pourra donc effectué
deux mandats supplémentaires à partir de
c'est l'un des quarante six amendements
sur les quais les russes sont prononcés
avant ce coup les précisions de notre
correspondant antoine frérot
les résultats ont été annoncés par la
commission électorale centrale et après
le dépouillement de l'intégralité des
bulletins de vote exprimés
ces amendements ont été soutenus par un
peu moins de 78 % pour être exact 77 92
% en faveur donc de ses arguments contre
21,27 contre dans le détail seuls une
région à en majorité voté contre sézanne
ans il s'agit du district autonome de
neil est située dans l'extrême nord de
la russie la région de moscou par
exemple a voté un peu plus de 65% en
faveur de ces amendements le taux de
participation s'élève à quasiment 68%
non loin du seuil officieux des 70%
alors aucun seuil de participation
n'était requis pour valider ce scrutin
il fallait seulement que ces amendements
soient soutenus par un peu plus par un
peu plus de la moitié des électeurs qui
se sont présentés à leur bureau de vote
on vient de le voir c'est bien le cas
ces amendements sont donc officiellement
adopté vous l'avez dit vladimir poutine
aura donc la possibilité de se présenter
pour deux mandats supplémentaires à
partir de 2024 mais il y a eu
bien d'autres amendements de confirmer
d'adopter via ce référendum la gare la
constitution garantit désormais que le
salaire minimum soit supérieur au
minimum vital et garantit également
l'indexation des retraites sur
l'inflation tous toutes celles ci toutes
ces mesures étaient attendues par une
large part de la population russe et
pour le premier ministre russe michail
mitch austin succès de ce référendum
impose de nouveaux objectifs au
gouvernement après le référendum d'hier
sur les amendements à la constitution
qui a confirmé que la société soutenait
la voie de développement du pays proposé
par le président le gouvernement fait
face à de nouveaux objectifs pour le
développement de notre pays dans tous
les domaines
la responsabilité personnelle de chacun
d'entre nous dans le cadre de son champ
d'action est ainsi renforcé époux
rosenberg ancien diplomate spécialiste
de la russie vladimir poutine cherche à
ce que la russie garde sa stabilité
l'ensemble de la presse a dit voilà
poutine avis c'est qu'ils cherchent à
faire élire ses probables personne
lançait on sera en 24 en tout cas il ya
encore quatre ans attend de patience ce
qu'il veut surtout est ce être maître
des horloges maître du calendrier il a
dit lui-même
si moi je ne présente pas et bien il y
aura là une espèce de pression il y aura
une lutte d'influencé
les clans parce qu'ils existent partout
vont dégainer un petit peu et c'est pas
du tout favorable à la pierre en
actuelle puisque il a dit là dans son
interview avant la grande parade ce que
la russie cherche comme beaucoup de pays
c'est la stabilité la sécurité la
prospérité alors évidemment il est le
mieux placé pour assurer cette triade
mais en attendant il veut calmer le jeu
et il veut surtout savoir si
éventuellement il se représente 6 choisi
un successeur
à 86 ans henri konan-bédié accepté le 20
juin dernier d'être le candidat du parti
démocratique de côte d'ivoire à
l'élection présidentielle ivoirienne du
31 octobre 2020 si la polémique autour
de son âge a suscité de vives réactions
il est pour certains un candidat
légitime les précisions de claire nico
le sphinx de daoukro n'a jamais aussi
bien porté son nom
henri konan-bédié est loin d'être un
inconnu dans le paysage politique
ivoirien président du pays entre 1993 et
1999 il a été renversé suite à un coup
d'état militaire
en 2010 il décide de se représenter
il arrive en troisième position à
l'issue du premier tour derrière laurent
gbagbo et alassane ouattara
cinq ans plus tard en 2015 il annonce
rallier la candidature d'alassane
ouattara et ne présente pas de candidat
au parti démocratique de côte d'ivoire
à 86 ans il revient donc sur le devant
de la scène en tant que candidat du pdc
y une candidature qui nourrit la
polémique auprès de la jeunesse
ivoirienne l'a pas lâché d'un riz qu'on
avait dix à quatre mais six as vraiment
il est âgé donc où se réveille et se
repose enfin qu'il présente quelqu'un
d'autre qu'il va guider qu'il va
conseiller croit sa mort
comme laisser le pouvoir à la jeunesse
pour que vraiment le pouvoir est dans la
jeunesse parce que la population
ivoirienne est formé des jeunes est la
maladie la pop laisse voir des jeunes et
je crois que nos jeunes ont roulé au
premier saponé l'instruction est en tout
cas je pense que haricots n'habitiez
divers laisser la place à la jeunesse
si l'agenda du président henri konan
bédié
après six ans vraiment c'est pas du tout
moi japon rejoint normale qui va c'est
le blues il vaut mieux nous en porter
euros auparavant l'âge limite pour être
candidat à la présidentielle en côte
d'ivoire était fixé à 75 ans une
restriction qui éliminé d'office
l'octogénaire mais en 2016 la
constitution est modifiée et l'âge
limite est levée l'ancienne disposition
constitutionnelle relativement à la
conditionnalité de l'âge pour être
président de la république fixe l
attelage limite à 75 ans est évidemment
monsieur laurent gbagbo monsieur
alassane ouattra msmb des dentelles
posthume c'est vrai
inapte à briguer la présidence de la
république
la réforme est intervenue l'âge limite a
été sautée aujourd'hui maison dans un
système de plus en plus libérale
relativement à cette conditionnalité
donc toute personne en côte d'ivoire
ayant plus de 35 ans peut valablement
vouloir briguer la présidence de la
république
un âge qui ne fait en tout cas pas débat
au sein du pdc y comme en témoigne jean
louis billon secrétaire exécutif du
parti vous savez le président bédié
c'est vrai il a un certain âge nous
l'appelons le vieux mais il est le seul
vieux dans l'équipe
l'équipe même et je ne voudrais que la
moyenne d'âge des cadres un pdci est
plus jeune que celle les autres partis
aujourd'hui l'âge du président bédié
c'est vrai est un âge avancé il a une
expérience il a connu plusieurs crises
dans le pays et il a su s'entourer de
cadres jeunes dynamiques et compétents
c'est surtout cela qui trouvera les les
électeurs vers en une équipe en face
d'eux ils verront des jeunes débattre
ils verront des compétences diverses et
variées en face d'eux et c'est ça le
plus important
henri konan-bédié a donc désormais
quatre mois de campagne électorale
devant lui pour tenter de convaincre le
peuple ivoirien qui se rendra aux urnes
le 31 octobre prochain est selon clément
yao journaliste et directeur du magazine
l'afrique la moyenne d'âge des
dirigeants africains n'est pas un
problème qu'on en beignets comme
d'autres mènent leur dernier combat
disons que c'est vrai bébé après le rco
la bd reste encore dans les cheveux pour
l'équipe puisque l'été quand dix
candidats à 2010 c'est le cas des
week-ends il a appelé ses partisans à
voter alassane ouattara mais vu la
composition politique la cua d'ivoire et
quand on voit encore la moyenne d'âge
alcoa bedia 4 6 ans et alassane ouattara
et la ba 118 laurent gbagbo que 75 à
lancer une génération qui est en train
de mimer les soldes et les combats et
quoi qu'on habite y est assez gênant
dans cette course à la présidentielle et
quoi réellement en ses chances il pense
que il a certainement ils ont un certain
nombre de rattraper puisque lui-même l'a
reconnu que la commune c'est notre
politique à force politique et même
personnel alors pour lui c'est le combat
de 2020 ce sera l'occasion pour lui de
réparer un peu tout ce que la plupart
comme erreurs aussi
et amener la cua d'ivoire c'est le
conseiller c'est un peu le leitmotiv qui
étaient là c'est au sein de cette
nouvelle coalition qu'il a pu mettre en
place laurent gbagbo du front populaire
ivoirien
c'est vrai que à 86 en premier parce que
en économie des actes et l'ajout dé plus
en possession de ses capacités on l'a vu
à m le paysan intervention en avoir et
qu'on habitait encore toute sa tête puis
faut considérer aussi l'aspect envoie
des cultures elles mêmes traditionnels
ou de l'afrique alors qu'à 3 600 genou
lui que le vieux c'est un peu le sage
un manifestation johannesbourg en
afrique du sud
une protestation contre les premiers
essais humains du potentiel vaccin
contre le corona virus et s'est fait
partie du programme développé par
l'université d'oxford en angleterre
quelques 2000 volontaires en afrique du
sud devraient y participer
[Musique]
cela va à l'encontre de tous les
protocoles et même si les gens vont
consentir il doit y avoir un
consentement éclairé
c'est une forme de violation du corps
d'une personne c'est une forme de viol
ce n'est pas acceptable nous pensons que
notre gouvernement ne soutient pas la
médecine traditionnelle ne reconnaît pas
non plus le travail des guérisseurs
traditionnels parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de médicaments que les
guérisseurs traditionnels pourrait
produire et qui pourrait aider avec le
colis de 19
nous pensons donc le gouvernement ne
soutient pas la médecine traditionnelle
des ong s'inquiètent du rachat de
philippe par google sans elle
beat l'un des leaders mondiaux des
objets connectés spécialisée dans les
activités sportives menace la protection
des données personnelles et risquent
d'accroître la position dominante du
géant américain
la commission européenne a jusqu'au 20
juillet pour autoriser ou non
l'opération écoutez l'analyse de cédric
dubuc avocat spécialiste des nouvelles
technologies ont été il y à deux niveaux
de réflexion le premier niveau c'est la
position dominante de google sur le
marché des données et le marché de la
publicité publicité en ligne tout
simplement
donc google a déjà une situation quasi
monopolistique elle va finalement
accroître sa position à la faveur de
cette acquisition c'est le premier sujet
c'est l'aggravation de la position
dominante de google
le second sujet c'est l'exploitation
finalement de cette position dominante
et les éventuels à lui à travers la
commercialisation de données qui sont
des données extraordinairement sensible
puisqu'il s'agit ni plus ni moins en
france et à la faveur du droit européen
que des données de santé données de
santé qui sont qualifiés comme tel
puisque extrêmement sensible puisque
résultant d'une combinaison du poids de
l'âge de la taille des individus donc la
question c'est dans quelle mesure de
rennes ou devrions-nous pardonnez moi
nous contenter des promesses de google
qui semble promettre de ne pas exploiter
exactement les données qui est
finalement sont et font le sel de cette
acquisition
bref c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous
avec l'actuel
et demain matin 7 heures du matin heure
française
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés
[Musique]
les contempler ces découvrir le regard
que portent les artistes sur leur époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet
et cet enfant couvert de toute la
tendresse de sa mère peint par elisabeth
vigée lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contre